war im bundestags gespräch und mit
parlamentarischen gästen ja vielen dank
an meine damen und herren draußen vor
dem reichstag demonstrieren zwei 3000
menschen das ist ihr gutes recht das ist
in einer demokratie so das volk ist der
souverän
sie wählen die bundestagsabgeordneten
und die wiederum kontrollieren die
exekutive und um dieses zusammenspiel
geht es ja auch hier in dem gesetz die
frage nämlich welchen spielraum die
exekutive in dem fall die
bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten haben sollen für
ihre entscheidungen in einer pandemie
und da gibt es eine ganze menge fragen
heute zweite dritte lesung nachher noch
im bundesrat voraussichtlich vom
bundespräsidenten heute abend noch
entschieden also ein ziemlich einiges
gesetz würde ich mal sagen und darüber
will ich diskutieren mit meinen beiden
gästen ich begrüße ganz herzlich carsten
schneider den ersten parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer der
spd-bundestagsfraktion und in der
gleichen funktion für die fdp marco
buschmann
herr schneider ich habe es gesagt
auffällig ist dann schon viel kritik an
diesem gesetz nicht nur von der
opposition auch von vielen menschen
draußen vielleicht weil der ein oder
andere diese sachzusammenhänge auch
nicht so ganz kennt deswegen bauen wir
darüber reden
ich hab mich ein bisschen gewundert wir
begleiten das ja schon länger warum sie
das so eine hier durchs parlament
prügeln unter anderem der bundesrat
heute nachmittag das ist glaube ich in
neun tagen die nächste bundesratssitzung
warum diese eile wir haben in der
die notlage in deutschland also müssen
die landesregierung die bundesregierung
alles dafür tun damit die pandemie
eingedämmt wird das du brauchst die
rechtsgrundlage die bisherige
rechtsgrundlage war sehr undefiniert
sehr unpräzise aus stammte vom frühjahr
diesen jahres und viele gerichte haben
in urteilen deutlich gemacht dass sie
die unterschicht ein abgebrühter
abwägungsentscheidungen für nicht
genügend begründet und ab und gesehen
haben aus diesem grund und sie haben
diese verordnungsermächtigung zu weit
gehend zu weitreichend das haben wir uns
als spd fraktion schon seit vier wochen
vier fünf wochen zurechtgelegt und auch
unser sprecher rechtspolitischer
sprecher hans fechner wohl etwas führen
müssen wir zur präzisierung touren
gutachten eingeholt und das findet sich
jetzt im gesetzentwurf
ein zweiter dritter lesung der ist ja
noch verändert worden das spricht für
das parlamentarische verfahren also wir
haben regulär zwei sitzungswochen wir
hatten eine woche der zwischenzeit wir
haben das vorher sitzungswoche
eingebracht werden eine anhörung und
dann gab's änderungsanträge die jetzt in
dieser woche beschlossen werden sondern
von daher ist das ein zügiges verfahren
klar aber ich sag mal wir haben jetzt
auch für ganz lange exegese fragen auch
keine zeit und von da ist
parlamentarische korrekt hätte sich
sicherlich das auch noch anders machen
können aber ich möchte dass wir bei
gebotene abwägung des
gesetzgebungsprozesses aber auch die
handlungsfähigkeit der bundesregierung
erhalten
gut also dass haben wir schon öfter
erlebt mittwoch seinen gesetzt dass der
bundesrat zusammen kommt ist eher
ungewöhnlich haben wir auch schon erlebt
bleibt es dabei jedenfalls wird das
gesetz heute abend wohl verabschiedet
werden die fdp wird da nicht mitmachen
sie haben ja im frühjahr mitgemacht als
die epidemische lage verabschiedet wurde
und einige rechte auf den
bundesgesundheitsminister die
bundesregierung verlagert wurde
jetzt hat man das gefühl wenn man fdp
politiker so reden hört die letzten ein
zwei tage als wenn das der untergang des
abendlandes wäre was hat sich da
zwischen geändert wir sind eine partei
der verfassung und des rechtsstaates und
wenn eine neue unbekannte gefahr
auftaucht dann ist es zulässig auch auf
sehr allgemeine rechtsgrundlagen
zurückzugreifen
deshalb war es im märz auch in ordnung
so zu arbeiten wie wir gearbeitet haben
aber je mehr wir über die gefahr wissen
je mehr wir auch über die instrumente
wissen die funktionieren desto höher
sind die anforderungen
der verfassung an eine präzise
rechtsgrundlage das ist ja genau das was
auch die gerichte entschieden und gesagt
haben deshalb musste die große koalition
sicher jetzt überhaupt bewegen obwohl es
da ja auch teile der koalition gehabt
die am liebsten immer so weiter gemacht
hätten und deshalb ist das kein
widerspruch sondern es ausdruck dass die
fdp die verfassungs partei ist dass die
exekutive etwas entscheidet das ist ganz
normal das ist jetzt nichts
verwerfliches wenn man bei den
demonstranten die ein oder andere rede
hört hat man ja das gefühl das sei schon
verwerflich
die frage ist die kontrolle sie sind
hier der oberste gesetzgeber und haben
eben hier mit der novellierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes den § 28a
mithin zugebracht und definieren 17
maßnahmen die zugegebenermaßen fast alle
schon ergriffen worden sind von der
bundeskanzlerin und den
ministerpräsidenten die kennen wir alle
schon diese maßnahmen sie haben eben
selber von den änderungsanträgen
gesprochen da fand ich ganz interessant
in der ersten lesung gab sie noch nicht
dann gab es die anhörung viele juristen
gesagt so geht das überhaupt nicht und
nun haben die änderungsanträge
eingebracht die ganz wichtig sind zum
beispiel nämlich dass diese maßnahmen
masken pflicht etc
alle nur vier wochen jeweils begrenzt
sind ist das genug kontrolle fürs
parlament
wir sind ja als parlament vollkommen
frei und unabhängig wir können ja
jederzeit auch gesetze aufheben werden
auch die pandemische lage aufheben
können so wie die fdp das beantragt
hatte hatte sich aber antrag das haben
wir nicht getan
ich respektiere die die vorschläge die
auch die fdp gemacht hat wir sind zu
einem anderen computer gekommen im kern
ist es so dass die mast dass die
maßnahmen die wir jetzt untersetzt haben
im gesetz als gesetzgeber tatsächlich
schon stattgefunden haben haben sie
recht sie wurden eben nur von den
gerichten als durch die
verordnungsermächtigung die zu unpräzise
war uns quasi aufgegeben dass wir das
auch gesetzlich normiert das tun wir
jetzt in einem abwägungsprozess
und wir haben ja auch die handlungen der
ministerpräsident und der kanzlerin als
sozialdemokraten für richtig von ihr war
noch eingebunden in der erarbeitung vom
wochenende dem vorschlag der kanzlerin
absehen denn fanden noch nicht korrekt
aber ansonsten ist das jetzt eine eine
klare präzisierung definition und es war
an dem ursprungstext entwurf eine erste
lesung schönen 28a drin bezogen auf die
mit 19 pandemie den haben wir in der tat
jetzt noch mal deutlich um gearbeitet
mir war es aber wichtig dass wir den
oppositionsfraktionen aber auch dem der
öffentlichkeit deutlich machen da wollen
wir etwas machen das ist der erste
entwurf wir machen die anhörung und dann
ändern wir das noch mal wenn es denn
klug ist und das hat sich ausgestelltes
um zu arbeiten wie im verfassungsrecht
auch gehör geschafft und jetzt hoffe ich
dass das so präzise genug ist christian
lindner der partei- und fraktionschef
der fdp hat heute morgen gesagt das ist
alles zu unpräzise das ist ein
blankoscheck das ist auch ein bisschen
pauschal oder nicht was kritisieren sie
konkret nein das ist exakt das was die
verfassungsrechtler in der anhörung
kritisiert haben denn eine rechtsnorm
besteht aus zwei teilen die rechtsfolgen
seite also die maßnahmen seite die ist
in der tat relativ ausführlich
beschrieben aber eine gute rechtsnorm
eine vollständige rechts man muss auch
auf der tatbestand seite präzise sein
also wann man genau diese maßnahmen oder
kombinationen dieser maßnahme greifen
kann
und da ist der jetzige entwurf genauso
wollte ich wie sein vorgänger
da wert von breit angelegten maßnahmen
und umfassenden maßnahmen gesprochen die
in bestimmten situationen zugelassen
sein sollen welche dieser 17 maßnahmen
und welche kombinationen dieser 17
maßnahmen denn jetzt umfassend oder
breit angelegt ist bleibt völlig offen
und das ist genau das was juristen zu
unbestimmt nennen also steckt dahinter
dann die unterstellung dass die
bundeskanzlerin die ministerpräsidenten
mit kanonen auf spatzen schießen werden
bisher mal das so nicht empfunden es gab
jetzt die letzte woche letzten tag ein
bisschen hin und her mit den beschlüssen
im kanzleramt das will ich gar nicht im
einzelnen diskutieren aber dennoch was
die opposition sagt die liegt ja auch
selber anträge vor die fdp hat also ein
dreistufiges verfahren wäre das nicht
sinnvoller gewesen dass man auch den
handelnden quasi vorschreibt welche
welche sachen sie die ergreifen dürfen
und welche halt nicht
also zunächst mal ist es ja so dass
dieser paragraf sich 820 allein auf die
jetzige pandemie lage bezieht und nach
der jetzigen wissenschaftliche
erkenntnis lage die wir haben wie sie
sich verbreitet 19 mögliche
handlungsoptionen die sind jetzt in der
abwägung und normierung auch quasi
genannt im gesetz das schon ein
deutlicher fortschritt
ich habe das von der fdp auch gesehen
ist die alternative wir sind zu einem
anderen verfahren gekommen
es deckt sich weitgehend mit dem was wir
als spd-fraktion vorige sitzungswoche
auch die fraktionen beschlossen haben
und ich hoffe und gehe davon aus dass
das auch jetzt wirklich so
verfassungskonform ist das anwendbar
sein kann man muss natürlich der
exekutive auf die jeweilige situation
vor ort den handlungsspielraum auch
lassen die es können ja unterschiedliche
strategien notwendig seien
ob es die infektionskette den schulen
sind oder ob es den gaststätten sind das
kann ich von hier aus ja nicht
betrachten und von daher bin ich der
auffassung wir haben erst noch die
gerichte die entscheiden können die dann
aber dann auch wenn man sich als der
bürger beeinträchtigt wird geklagt
werden kann
aber eben aber auch die notwendige
handlungsfreiheit vor ort in den ländern
oder in den städten dort agieren zu
können
der parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
linken herr korte der geht einen schritt
weiter und sagt jede grund
rechtsänderung gehört hier ins parlament
und wenn sie halt nachträglich beraten
wird also es ist so wir sind in unserem
gesetzentwurf auch der meinung wenn die
bundeskanzlerin im rahmen föderaler
koordinierung möchte dass eben die
grundrechte von millionen von menschen
eingegriffen wird dann sollte man vorher
dem bundestag da um zustimmung bitten
das ist ja so wenn die bundeskanzlerin
beispielsweise im rahmen der euro
rettung nach brüssel fährt oder wenn
dort beispielsweise bestimmte zustimmung
erteilt werden soll dann muss man auch
das parlament fragen und ich glaube der
millionenfache eingriff in grundrechte
ist mindestens genauso wichtig und warum
macht man das nicht herr schneider das
ist unbenommen also wir normieren ja
wann das notwendig sein kann und
unbenommen ist dass wir als gesetzgeber
als bundestag jederzeit darauf dass auch
machen können noch und könnten auch das
missbilligen und können der anträge
stellen die im anderen fall eben auch zu
einer anderen handlung für mich kann ich
aber sagen dass zumindest was die
koalitionsfraktion betrifft so ist dass
wir diese entscheidungsfindung welche
maßnahmen getroffen werden eingebunden
sind
die fdp und die grünen wahrscheinlich
über ihre landesregierung auch und dann
auch zustimmen oder auch nicht zustimmen
von daher dass eine eben eine einholen
die genehmigungs andere ist dass wir es
auch aus quasi zurückholen können davon
ist der bundestag jederzeit frei von der
ist das instrumentarium relativ ähnlich
sie sprachen gerade ministerpräsidenten
an die spielen eine wichtige rolle
nachher auch im bundesrat und von denen
kamen ja unter anderem der wunsch so
einen 28a einzuflechten und der wunsch
dass eben was viele nicht wissen die
bundeskanzlerin exekutiert die maßnahmen
nicht sondern die länderchefs in ihren
ländern das eben klare maßgaben für das
handeln dann vorhanden sind das war ja
ein wunsch auch von den
ministerpräsidenten
das war ja ein minimum denn wenn sie in
grundrechte eingreifen dann gilt der vor
bald das gesetz ohne ein ausreichend
bestimmtes gesetz dürfen sie das nicht
das ist das wesen des freiheitlichen
rechtsstaates nur diese lösung die die
koalition jetzt vorlegt ist unser maß
unserer ansicht nach kein ausreichend
bestimmtes gesetz
es ist eben der blankoscheck und es ist
zu streng sind keine ausnahmen
beispielsweise für betriebe vorgesehen
die hygiene konzepte haben die infektion
so gut wie unmöglich machen es ist kein
entschädigungsanspruch normiert und es
sind auch dinge drin wie die sogenannten
ausgangs beschränkungen das ist ja schön
sprich für ausgangssperren das sind
maßnahmen die sind unverhältnismäßig
weil wenn sie ihre wohnung verlassen
gefährden sie erst mal niemanden erst
der kontakt macht gefährlich wenn sie
das gesetz lesen da kommt der artikel 7
sind artikel gesetzt da steht drinnen
eingriffe in die grundrechte unter
anderem die unversehrtheit der wohnung
da kann ich mich an herrn lauterbach
erinnern dass schon mal angesprochen hat
wie weit darf der gesetzgeber da gehen
die wohnung ist heilig und dieses wird
auch nicht passieren dass wie das
insulin julia initiiert wurde das dort
eingegriffen wird
das bleibt auch ich kann nur sagen diese
pandemie bekämpfen wir nur gemeinsam mit
klugen verstand solidarität und
rücksichtnahme und denn da große partys
gefeiert werden dann ist das eine
gefährdung unserer allgemeinen
gesundheit und ich glaube ich glaube an
das verständnis bevölkerung mehrheitlich
in deutschland ist das nicht passiert
sie müssen beide gleich weg deswegen
abschließend herr buschmann wenn man
strich drunter machen ist das gremium
mit der kanzlerin und den
ministerpräsidenten nicht genau das
richtige gremium um das zu entscheiden
oder würden sie sagen nee das ist genau
zu klein wir müssen es hier im bundestag
debattieren und dann auch entscheiden
und ist man dann schnell genug wenn es
um entscheidungen geht die millionenfach
in grundrechte eingreifen
dann ist das richtige gremium dafür das
parlament hier muss die regierung im
parlament vorlegen was ihre strategie
ist was ihre gründe sind was ihre
hinten sind und dann müssen die
demokratisch gewählten volksvertreter in
eine entscheidungs einfluss darauf sein
üben nichts verändert die
lebenssituation der menschen im moment
so sehr wie die korona maßnahmen darüber
muss das parlament befinden und das wird
jetzt hier diskutieren herr buchner
schneider vielen dank sie sind beide die
parlamentarischen geschäftsführern
müssen gleich rein denn es gibt eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte meine damen und
herren darüber werden wir gleich mehr
erfahren wir schalten schon mal rein da
sehen sie schon mal dass der
bundespräsident noch nicht da ist und
dann kann ich ihnen noch mal sagen wir
haben heute ja also das dritte gesetz
zum schutz der bevölkerung bei einer
epidemischen lage mit nationaler
tragweite viel diskutiert wird dort über
den § 28a die grundrechts
einschränkungen aber dieses gesetz
umfasst noch wesentlich mehr da geht es
zum beispiel um die aufforderung an die
länder impfzentren einzurichten bis zum
15 dezember es geht unter anderem über
die verlängerung der verdienstausfälle
für eltern wenn sie eben ihren beruf
nicht ausüben können wir sie die kinder
zu hause betreuen müssen dieses geld
wird verlängert bis zum 31 märz und es
geht darum dass zb die kliniken die
viele operationen jetzt absagen müssen
dass diese kliniken auch geld kriegen
damit sie nicht etwa ins minus laufen
nur deshalb weil sie heben die betten
freiheiten für mögliche cupid patienten
heute haben wir ungefähr 946 mit kranke
weniger als vor einer woche die kurve
von diesem wellenbrecher die schwächt
sich nur sehr sehr langsam ab und die
bundeskanzlerin hatte ja vor drei wochen
schon noch einmal mehr maßnahmen
angemahnt jetzt vor wenigen tagen gab es
ja ein ziemliches hin und her zwischen
ihr und den ministerpräsidenten aber
dennoch hat die bundeskanzlerin im
weitblick natürlich recht gehabt man
muss etwas tun um diese epidemie welle
zu stoppen wir sehen hier den
bundesinnenminister die masken pflicht
ist nur eine von vielen möglichkeiten
und wenn es gar nicht anders geht wie in
österreich
dann müsste man sogar noch eine
vollbremsung einlegen jetzt ist der
bundestagspräsident da jetzt geht s los
hier im deutschen kollegen bitte nehmen
sie platz
der sitzung ist eröffnet für die heutige
191 192 und die 193 freitag konnte
zwischen den fraktionen keine
tagesordnung vereinbart werden die
fraktion der afc hat den vorschlag der
anderen fraktionen widersprochen
also habe ich den bundestag mit der von
den anderen fraktionen vorgeschlagen
tagesordnung einberufen und § 120 absatz
3 der geschäftsordnung ist für die
genehmigung der tagesordnung ein blinder
beschluss erforderlich
es ist in der fraktion l vereinbart
worden
diese noch zu beschließende tagesordnung
um den zusatzpunkt die liste
aufgeführten punkte zu erweitern von der
frist werde beginne beratung soll soweit
erforderlich abgewichen werden nach
tagesordnungspunkt 5 soll als
zusatzpunkt ein antrag der fraktion der
cdu/csu und spd mit dem titel
nationalismus und rassismus die stirn
bieten einfluss der ökobewegung
zurückdrängen aufgesetzt werden in
verbundener debatte soll mit diesen
zusatzpunkt tagesordnungspunkt 19
aufgerufen werden sowie ein antrag der
fraktion die linke aufgesetzt werden
der tagesordnungspunkt 7 und 8 zu wahlen
von stellvertretern des präsidenten
sollen abgesetzt werden
tagesordnungspunkt 10 wird am freitag
nach tagesordnungspunkt 28 aufgerufen
an dieser stelle sollen drei vorlagen
der fraktion der fdp zum thema
gentechnik aufgesetzt werden
anstelle des tagesordnungspunkts 19 soll
ein antrag der fraktion der afg zum
thema nationale sicherheitsstrategie
aufgesetzt werden
die tagesordnungspunkte 14 p c und d 25
b und c 29 30 b sowie 33 j sollen
abgesetzt werden
ich mache außerdem
auf die im anhang zur zusatzpunkte liste
aufgeführten überweisungen aufmerksam
und damit kommen wir zur feststellung
der tagesordnung für die 191 193 sitzung
mit diesen genannten änderungen und
ergänzungen wer stimmt für diese
tagesordnung
wer stimmt dagegen gibt es den
teilnehmern dann ist die tagesordnung
gegen die stimmen der afd
so beschlossen
der kunde erst rufe ich auf die
tagesordnung oder sie kommt geht alles
ich würde gerne zunächst die bemerkung
machen liebe kollegen kollegen wir haben
als wir ende märz zum ersten mal unter
corona bedingungen wie der plenarsitzung
gemacht haben vereinbart das wird es mit
einer begrenzten präsenz im plenarsaal
machen das ist eine vereinbarung
zwischen den fraktionen damit wir
gewissen abstand halten und ähnliches
mehr
es ist klar dass durch solche
vereinbarung kein mitglied des deutschen
bundestags von der teilnahme an einer
sitzung des deutschen bundestags
abgehalten werden kann
das ist ein verfassungsmäßiges recht es
ist klar
deswegen haben wir neben den
neben den plätzen in dem eigentlich für
abgeordnete vorgesehenen teil des
plenarsaals haben wir auf den tribünen
zusätzliche plätze für abgeordnete die
wir wo wir im übrigen auch mikrofone
haben soll dass alle die kolleginnen und
kollegen die sich auf den tribünen
beteiligen aber nicht bitte nicht die
journalisten sondern abgeordnete des
deutschen bundestags zu zwischenfragen
und ähnliche bemerkungen zu wort melden
können sprechen können auch vom platz
auch das ist gewährleistet wenn nach
alledem die plätze so wie wir sie
geplant haben im plenarsaal nicht so
ganz ausreichen dann verweise ich auf
die allgemeinverfügung die der präsident
irgendwann anfang september glaube ich
oder abgegeben wo er gesagt hat dass im
bereich des bundestags mund nasen
abdeckung verpflichtend ist dass man sie
ablegen kann wenn man an seinem platz
sitzt und genügend abstand hat wenn man
dazu den abstand einhalten kann bitte
die maske aufsetzen
notfalls kann auch im stehen an der
plenarsitzung teilnehmen
auch das will ich um etwaige
beunruhigungen zu im vorhinein zu
unterbinden
hier noch einmal gesagt haben nachdem
dies alles geklärt ist haben wir jetzt
die voraussetzung das war eine debatte
führen können die den zweck erfüllte
unsere aufgabe ist nämlich in
schwierigen zeiten als parlament und
gesetz gebe auf der basis ganz
unterschiedlicher meinungen und
gründlicher beratungen entscheidungen zu
treffen und dazu rufe ich auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 11 d und die
zusatzpunkte eins bis drei zweite und
dritte beratung des von den fraktionen
der cdu/csu und spd eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zum schutz der bevölkerung
bei einer epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite und beratung des
antrags der koalitionsfraktionen zur
feststellung des fortbestands der
epidemische lage national
und beratung weitere vorlagen zur
demokratischen kontrolle jacobi 19
maßnahmen zu entschädigungszahlungen für
eltern im home office zu einer strategie
für corona impfstoffe sowie zu einem
sofortprogramm intensivpflege und jetzt
hat der kollege bau waren das wort zu
geschäft so gewünscht und hiermit
erteile jedes wort zur geschäftsordnung
bernd baumann ist der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der afg
die fdp ist durch ihn jetzt einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag vorstellen
herr präsident meine damen und herren
die heutige gesetzesvorlage ist eine
ermächtigung der regierung wie es das
zeitgeschichtliche zeiten nicht mehr gab
der verfassungsrechtler und ehemaligen
bundesminister der cdu
rupert scholz mit den vorgang jetzt
schlicht verfassungswidrig und zugleich
ist das ganze fachlich eine gesetzes-
und eine eilige flickschusterei meine
damen und herren die fdp beantragt heute
die rücküberweisung des gesetzentwurfs
in die ausschüsse
wir können ihnen heute nicht debattieren
der antrag muss runter von der
tagesordnung meine damen und herren
unglaubliches mussten die abgeordneten
erleben wie sie berichten der wichtigste
parlamentarische ausschuss in dieser
angelegenheit ist der federführende
gesundheitsausschuss er sollte am montag
um 10 uhr 30 tagen entscheidende
änderungsanträge lieferte die regierung
aber erst kurz davor um halbzehn eng
bedruckte 36 seiten niemand konnte das
lesen oder inhaltlich kritisieren oder
auch nur überfliegen kein mensch
trotzdem peitschten die koalitionspartei
mit ihrer mehrheit trotzdem falsch die
koalitionsparteien mit ihrer mehrheit
dieses wichtige und so problematische
gesetz durch den ausschuss was für eine
arrogante missachtung des parlaments das
dürfen wir nicht zulassen
geben sie die vorlage zurück in die
ausschüsse meine damen und herren im eu
ausschuss fordert uns berichtet tötete
der obmann der spd lauthals der
spd-obmann man könne dem gesetzentwurf
nicht zustimmen änderungsanträge seien
viel zu kurzfristig eingegangen ist für
die jede zeit zur prüfung man lehne ihn
daher ab am ende stimmte die spd im
ausschuss dann aber zu obwohl sie
eigentlich obwohl sie eigentlich dagegen
war kann man sich als parlamentarier
mehr verbiegen früher hatten
sozialdemokraten war rückgrat ich
erinnere mich noch zeit von helmut
schmidt das ist lange vorbei meine damen
und herren
ein ähnliches
eine ähnliche spricht akten im
rechtsausschuss die vorlagen kommt hier
zu spät manche wurden gar nicht
verschickt alle oppositionsfraktionen
begehrten dagegen auf sie wurden eiskalt
über stimmt das gesetz ohne echte
beratung auch durch diesen ausschuss
gedrückt dabei ist es das wichtigste
oder einzelne wichtigsten in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik keines
schnitt tiefer ein in die
freiheitsrechte der menschen
berufsfreiheit reisefreiheit freiheit
der person versammlungsfreiheit
demonstrationsfreiheit unverletzlichkeit
der wohnung und und und sowas muss man
doch in den ausschüssen besprechen und
beraten das geht nicht im hauruck
verfahren
meine damen und herren resümiert merkels
gesetzentwurf unter punkt c alternativen
doppelpunkt keine typisch merkel mal
wieder alternativlos aber es gibt eine
alternative für deutschland
es war auch zur geschäftsordnung der
kollege grosse-brömer cdu csu
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sie haben soeben erlebt wie ein
politisch ertrinkender verzweifelt nach
halt sucht sie saufen saufen politisch
ab was ich keine themen haben keine
ideen und keine antworten auf die
herausforderungen der zeit deswegen
müssen sich mit geschäftsordnung bis
erzählen gestalten können sie nicht
gestalten können sie nicht sie können
nur dagegen
und das ist einfach größtenteils mit
verleumdungen im unwahrheiten verbunden
gesagt sie wissen das und deswegen sind
sie so getroffen gerade sie mögen wir
die rechnung nicht aufgehen die menschen
im lande sind nicht so dumm ihnen auf
den leib zu gehen beschäftigen sich
damit
versuchen sie mal programmatisch zu
arbeiten ich weiß das ist ungewohnt für
sie aber es lohnt sich
wir schließen heute wir schließen heute
ein vollkommen geordnetes
gesetzgebungsverfahren ab
[Applaus]
an dem das parlament massiv beteiligt
war ja sie nicht weil sie sich nicht
eingebracht haben
herr brenner ihre maske wissen nicht
richtig
alle das ist völlig unstreitig alle
vorgaben unserer verfassung unserer
geschäftsordnung werden eingehalten
haben sie irgendwelche argumente gehört
hier vor hin wo das nicht der fall sein
soll
fehlanzeige erster lesung anhörungen
beratungen im ausschuss stunden lang
vielleicht waren sie da nicht weiter
herr bohmann vielleicht haben sie es
nicht mitbekommen aber alle anderen
haben gearbeitet stundenlang an diesem
gesetz und wir beschließen den übrigen
heute ein gesetz das für klarheit und
rechtssicherheit sorgt für allen für die
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
wir beschließen ist heute weil die
befugnisse der exekutive der regierungen
konkret definiert werden sie werden
enger und nicht weiter gefasst und wir
beschließen ist auch damit noch klarer
wir dass der bundestag das erste und das
letzte wort zu diesen maßnahmen hat
damit das klar ist damit das klar ist
dieses gesetz ist nicht nur ein
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz dieses gesetz
ist vor allen dingen ein parlaments
stärkung gesetz weile darunter
und wir beschließen es hier beschließen
es deshalb weil wir zur bekämpfung der
pandemie weiter handeln müssen weil es
um menschenleben geht und weil wir
zustände wie in unseren nachbarländern
nicht wollen und verhindern wollen
das ist der punkt um den es geht meine
damen und herren einer von der truppe
von ihrer truppe hat sich verplappert
verkürzt verkürzen
er hat gesagt der afg geht es gut wenn
es deutschland schlecht geht das ist ihr
credo
deshalb wollen sie dieses gesetz nicht
wir machen da nicht mit wir wollen dass
deutschland diese pandemie besiegt wir
wollen das gemeinsam machen demokratisch
und entschlossen und deswegen
beschließen wir heute dieses gesetz
gibt zwei treffer auf meldung zur
geschäftsordnung herr kollege buschmann
marco buschmann der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer marco
buschmann der erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der fdp meine sehr
geehrten kolleginnen und kollegen
welchem grund können die man als seriöse
oppositionsfraktionen für diesen antrag
haben
vielleicht weil man noch keine meinung
entwickeln konnte zu diesem gesetz ich
glaube das war möglich die linke lehnt
es ab die grünen sind dafür wir lehnen
es ab wenn sie immer noch nicht wissen
wie sie zu 28 jahre hier feststehen dann
ist das ihr problem und nicht das
problem dieses hauses welche
welchen seriösen weiteren grund könnte
man anführen um diesen
geschäftsordnungsantrag zu stellen weil
man vielleicht änderungsvorschläge diese
sogenannten alternativen die sie ja im
namen führen
im ausschuss war von ihnen nichts zu
hören nichts haben sie vorgelegt die
grünen haben ein änderungsantrag
vorgelegt wir haben einen neuen
abschnitt vorlegen über 16 sein
es war möglich alternativen zu
formulieren sie reden nur darüber wir
tun es und dass wir es getan haben zeigt
dass es geht meine damen und herren
in wahrheit geht ihnen um was ganz
anderes
der antrag ist ja nicht am montag und
ich am dienstag angekündigt worden
sondern gestern abend heute morgen
stellte es sich so ein was ist der wahre
grund seien sie doch ehrlich sie haben
gemerkt dass ihre radikalen freunde da
draußen im social media dazu aufrufen
die wege ins parlament zu blockieren und
weil sie die für sich einnehmen wollen
wollen sie genau so den weg der
gesetzgebung blockieren wie die da
draußen den weg ins parlament blockieren
wollen
sie wollen sich mit versammeln hinter
ermächtigungsgesetz und sonstigen
banalisierung sie wollen die
institutionen den schmutz ziehen weil
sie sie hassen und das ist der
eigentliche beweggrund für das was sie
jetzt zu uns sie haben keine
alternativen sie wollen nur krawall
machen und bei diesem quatsch machen
wenn ich mit das gesetz das die groko
vorliegt es ist schlecht aber es
errichtet keine diktatur
[Applaus]
nächster hinter zur geschäftsordnung
sich der kollege carsten schneider spd
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir sind heute hier zwölf
zusammengekommen um ein gesetz zu ändern
das souvenir novellieren das
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz habe kollege
buschmann hat gerade darauf hingewiesen
dass draußen demonstrationen stattfinden
dass es aufrufe auch von ihrer fraktion
der afg gehabt die eingänge zu
blockieren
die dem gesetzgeber bei seiner arbeit zu
behindern weil er sehr verehrten damen
und herren ich bin den vielen
polizistinnen und polizisten sind über
2000 die heute hier in berlin aus neuen
bundesländern da sind dankbar dass sie
ihren job machen größte gelegenheit
geben farbe zu machen auch nicht zu
beraten und nicht wie sie nicht wie sie
mit der angst oder sorge der menschen in
deutschland zu spielen und letztendlich
nur zu provozieren das zeigt auch ihr
outfit heute weil es ihnen aber nichts
anderes geht als die institution des
bundestages die institution unserer
verfassung der bundesrat heute auch gut
vertragen vertreten in den dreck zu
ziehen zu diskreditieren will ich hier
klar sagen das verfahren das wir gewählt
haben ist ein zügiges angesichts der
pandemie lage ist das aber auch
notwendig es ist aber es ist aber im
rahmen der demokratischen
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten
wir hatten eine erste lesung in der
letzten sitzungswoche hier
dazu haben verschiedene gesprochen auch
sie haben die gelegenheit dann gab es
den gesetzentwurf den wir ergänzt haben
um 1 § 28a der ist bekannt den haben wir
eingebracht als fraktion
wir haben danach in der sitzungswoche
darauf eine anhörung stattfinden lassen
sachgerecht die kolleginnen und kollegen
der opposition wurden auch informiert
über die änderungen die wir als
koalition auch planen und dann haben wir
tatsächlich folgendes gemacht wir haben
diesen 28a der nur für diese eine
pandemie geht umgeschrieben verändert
mit der erkenntnis durch die
sachverständigen und auch der debatte
die wir hier im parlament hatten dafür
will ich mich ganz herzlich bedanken
ich halte das
ich halte das für ein zwingend
notwendigen prozess dass hier auch immer
deutlich zu machen dass ihre irreführung
dazu führt die demokratie zu
diskreditieren und einsatz will ich hier
noch sagen einsatz will ich hier noch
sagen aus ihren stimmen aus ihren reihen
kommt das gerede dass verächtlich machen
des parlaments vor allen dingen noch mit
bezügen auf das jahr 1933 sie haben das
hier als keyword wieder an getextet herr
baum mal mit der ermächtigung es geht
diesmal vergleich mit einem
ermächtigungsgesetz und ich sage ihnen
als ich sage ihnen als sozialdemokrat
einer fraktion die 1933 hier nicht hier
im reichstag soll nach europa durch die
spaliere der ss marschiert ist wohl
wissend dass ihnen danach der tod drohen
kann und er ihn auch gedroht wir konnten
unsere sozialdemokraten konnten noch
hierher gehen haben abgestimmt und haben
gegen diese ermächtigungsgesetz gestimmt
die kommunisten waren leider schon oder
war uns schon ausgeschlossen kz oder
anderswo meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wenn leute wie sie mit solchen
geschichtlichen parallelen spielen
sie diskreditieren nicht in unserer
demokratie sondern sie machen sie
verächtlich und genau das wollen sie
berlin
vielen dank
weitere wortmeldungen zur
geschäftsordnung liegen mir nicht vor
die fraktion der afg hat die
zurückverweisung der vorlage beantragt
wer stimmt für diesen
geschäftsordnungsantrag die fdp ist
dagegen
[Musik]
wer enthält sich dann ist der
geschäftsordnungsantrag gegen die
stimmen der afg mit den stimmen des
übrigen hauses abgelehnt zur zweiten
beratung des gesetzentwurfes der
koalitionsfraktionen legt je einen
änderungsantrag der fraktion der fdp und
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen vor
über beide änderungsanträge sowie über
den gesetzentwurf und den antrag der
fraktion der cdu/csu und spd zur
feststellung des fortbestands der
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite werden wir später namentlich
abstimmen also insgesamt vier
namentliche abstimmung
der ablauf ist wie folgt vorgesehen die
beiden änderungsanträge werden am ende
der zweiten beratung als erstes parallel
namentlich abgestimmt
dafür werden 30 minuten vorgesehen und
währenddessen beginnen wir mit der
befragung der bundesregierung für die
heute dann der bundesarbeitsminister zur
verfügung steht
sobald die ergebnisse der namentlichen
abstimmung über die beiden
änderungsantrag vorliegen werden wir die
regierungsbefragung dank unterbrechen
sie haben dankenswerterweise gelegt und
kommen dann auf die zweite beratung des
gesetzentwurfs zurück und die
schlussabstimmung sollte dann wieder
namentlich mit einer dauer von 30
minuten erfolgen
nach verkündigung des ergebnises dieser
dritten namentlichen abstimmung erfolgen
alle weiteren einfachen abstimmungen
sowie die vierte namentliche abstimmung
über den antrag der koalitionsfraktionen
zur feststellung des fortbestands der
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite wiederum mit einer dauer
an heimlichen abschiebung von 30 minuten
alle damen abstimmungen finden in der
weststadt für die aussprache wurde eine
dauer von 60 minuten beschlossen und
jetzt ja eigentlich die aussprache der
teil das war der kollegin karin maag
cdu/csu und herren da mir einen genauen
fahrplan vom bundestagspräsidenten
bekommen und jetzt geht es los mit der
erwarteten debatte ihr zweiter lesung
karin maag die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der unionsfraktion und
kollegen und vor allem liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger ich weiß
insbesondere ihnen haben wir im letzten
halben jahr viel abverlangt und ich bin
allen dankbar die die maßnahmen zur
eindämmung der pandemie bisher
mitgetragen haben und auch weiterhin
mittragen in den vielen einen sieg
telefonaten und gesprächen während
dieser zeit aber auch zu diesem gesetz
konkret habe ich echte sorge gespürt und
sie alle bitte ich leiden sie bei uns
bilden sie sich ihre meinung anhand der
debatten der demokratischen parteien im
bundestag
trauen sie nicht einigen wenigen die
unter dem deckmantel grundrechte
schützen zu wollen uns abgeordnete
diskreditieren oder gar nicht behindern
wollen die lass mich jedenfalls durch
solche angriffe nicht einschüchtern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen befinden
wir uns weiterhin in einer kritischen
phase bei der pandemie und der verlauf
der letzten paar tage lässt zwar hoffen
dass wir die infektions dynamik
unterbrechen konnten von einer wieder
beherrschbarkeit des infektionsgeschehen
sind wir noch deutlich entfernt
und dieses dritte bevölkerungsschutz
gesetz ist deshalb insbesondere wegen
der weiteren maßnahmen zur eindämmung
dieses virus so dringend notwendig wir
bereiten gegen diesem gesetz vor allem
das verfahren für die endlich greifbaren
impfungen vor die technischen
einzelheiten überlassen wir dann der
rechtsverordnung des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums und
ersetzen ebenfalls im gesetz den
rechtsrahmen für eine impfstrategie wir
regeln in anspruch auf schutz impfung
und vorrangige berücksichtigung
besonders wohlhabende personen gruppen
berücksichtigt werden zum beispiel aber
auch menschen die diese gruppen pflegen
der handel oder betreuung und übrigens
jetzt achtung wir sehen einen anspruch
auf die impfung vor und keine
impfpflicht
deswegen bieten wir die zahnärztlichen
tierärztlichen laboren ihm zu den
laboruntersuchungen einwirkt besonders
viele wohl marable gruppen zu schützen
dies sagt wissen dafür einen anspruch
auf ft2 schutzmasken vor allen dingen um
das ansteckungsrisiko nochmal zu
vermindern und diesen anspruch mit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen haben wir
unionsabgeordnete übrigens gegen viele
widerstände durchgesetzt
wie gesagt nur als liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen brauchen bei den aktuellen
intensiv zahlen vor allem liquidität
wenn sie für notwendige behandlungen
erneut wie im märz planbare operationen
verschieden müssen zugunsten der kobik
19 patienten und anders als noch im
frühjahr unterstützen wir heute gezielt
die kliniken die notwendige
versorgungsstrukturen vorweisen konkret
also diejenigen der stufen zwei und drei
die an der notfallversorgung teilnehmen
liebe kollegen liebe kollegin in den
vergangenen wochen wurde deutlich dass
es weitere präzisierung im
infektionsschutzgesetz bedarf stichworte
sind wie fortdauernd notwendigen kontakt
beschränkungen bisher keine speziellen
medikamente impfstoff ist noch nicht
verfügbar
und ich habe es noch nie erlebt dass ein
gesetz so missverstanden wurde mit § 8
die infektionsschutzgesetz und weiten
wir gerade nicht den handlungsspielraum
der regierung aus sondern wir nehmen ihn
ein
viele politische lage feststellt und
solange diese feststellung andauert kann
nicht exekutive bestimmte vorgegebene
maßnahmen ausführen und anordnen und das
ganze mittels recht zuordnung und sobald
wir abgeordnete die epidemische lage
beenden sind diese maßnahmen hinfällig
die massnahmen bleiben auch gerichtlich
in vollem umfang überprüfbar beschränkt
auch nicht einseitig irgendwelche
grundrechte ein sondern wir setzen in §
28a den rahmen den rechtsrahmen für den
ausgleich dieser politik es geht doch
nicht nur interesse derjenigen die von
den einschränkungen betroffen sind die
die ausbreitung des virus verhindern
wollen wir alle der staat ist doch auch
dem schutz des lebens und der
körperlichen unversehrtheit all jener
verpflichtet die durch die pandemie
gefährdet sind das ist doch die wahrheit
neuen kollegen wir alle dürfen es auch
nicht hinnehmen dass meine ich betone
manche den bots den verschwörungs
erzähler und den sportlern denjenigen
die unseren staat grundsätzlich ablehnen
mehr vertrauen als uns im parlament und
ich will um das vertrauen der großen
mehrheit in unsere demokratie
in unseren rechtsstaat und ich unsere
institutionen kämpfen wir
unionsabgeordneten sind davon überzeugt
dass dieses gesetz ein gutes gesetz ist
wir sind davon überzeugt dass wir
nachher dem antrag die pandemie die
pandemische lage weiter fortzusetzen
zustimmen können ich alle empfehle ihnen
zustehen und herzlichen dank
soweit also karen markt die das hier
noch einmal vorgestellt hat ganz wichtig
war ihr und das muss man auch noch mal
betonen weil auch draußen bei den
demonstrationen da wirklich falsche
sachen formation behauptet werden es
gibt keine impfpflicht
es werden impfzentren von den ländern
geforderte sollen bis zum 15
dezember aufgebaut werden eine
impfpflicht steht in diesem gesetz
ebenfalls nicht drin
alexander gauland der eine
fraktionsvorsitzende der afd
meine damen und herren vertrauen ist
eine der wichtigsten ressourcen der
gesellschaft
man kann es bekanntlich verspielen wenn
menschen einander nicht mehr vertrauen
ende der wille zur kooperation unter
sind steht unfrieden
wenn teile der bevölkerung der regierung
nicht vertrauen bilden sich risse im
gesellschaftlichen gefüge wenn die
regierung und regierungsnahe medien
diese teile der bevölkerung
stigmatisieren und beschimpfen oder gar
mit dem verfassungsschutz bedrohen statt
mit ihnen zu reden werden diese risse
tiefer und das misstrauen wird größer
und meine damen und herren wenn
abgeordnete von der polizei zu boden
geworfen werden dann darf man fragen wo
sind ja eigentlich angekommen in diesem
land
in einem rechtsstaat wird das
grundvertrauen institutionell gesichert
durch die grundrechte meine damen und
herren
heribert prantl bei gott kein freund der
anstieg der chef kommentator der
süddeutschen zeitung hat dazu
bemerkenswerte worte geschrieben und
gesprochen
ich zitiere mit zustimmung des
präsidenten grundrechte heißen
grundrechte weil sie die grundlagen
unseres lebens bilden grundrechte sind
gerade für die notzeiten da wenn sie in
krisen und notzeiten weggeschoben werden
dann sind sie nichts wert dann kann man
sie vergessen heribert prantl nicht
alexander gauland das
infektionsschutzgesetz der
bundesregierung ist die größte
grundrechts einschränkung in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
wenn wir den gedankengang von herrn
brandt fortsetzen heisst das wir können
die grundrechte vergessen das misstrauen
meine damen und herren wird explodieren
das sehen sie auf den straßen das sehen
sie in der aggression die sie überall
spüren und sie sehen es in vielen
städten und heute auch woody bundestag
diese menschen treten für ihre
grundrechte ein und müssen nicht vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet werden
viele bürger haben existenzielle sorgen
und fragen sie wollen nicht nur wissen
wie es mit ihren geschäften lokalen oder
kulturstätten weiter gehen soll sondern
sie fürchten angesichts ausgesetzt für
grundrechte um ihre freiheit krone
kontakt verfolgung digitale
gesundheitskontrolle indirekte
impfpflicht das sind ja alle symptome
einer nahenden smarten
gesundheitsdiktatur die menschen fragen
sich beispielsweise ob sie nachteile
haben werden wenn sie nicht impfen oder
nicht registrieren lassen wollen
kommt man dann eines tages nicht mehr
ins restaurant oder zum sport oder ins
ausland wir so etwas fragt die nennt man
bekanntlich verschwörungstheoretiker
doch in china ist diese art
totalüberwachung bereits fakt und wir
wollen auf diesem wege kein stück mit
geben
die faz die haben wir nicht zu nahe
treten wird wenn man sie regierungsnahen
twittert die hohen corona zahlen in
vielen westlichen ländern werfen die
beunruhigende frage auf ob offene
gesellschaften weniger geeignet sind auf
globale bedrohungen zu reagieren als
autoritäre systeme wie will dort jemand
schon mit dem zaunpfahl winken in einer
sachverständigen stellungnahme hat die
vertreterin des lehrstuhls für
öffentliches recht der ruhr universität
bochum vor dem gesundheitsausschuss des
bundestages ausgeführt zitat der
geplante § 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes genügt den
vorgaben von parlamentsvorbehalt und
bestimmt heitz grundsatz nicht die
vorschrift lässt keinerlei abwägung den
grundrechtlich betroffenen interessen
erkennen sondern will offenbar einseitig
das bisherige vorgehen während der
korona epidemie legitimieren so die
sachverständige im gesundheitsausschuss
keinerlei abwägung so verhält es sich
denn was ist es anders als maßlos und
unausgewogen wenn die unverletzlichkeit
der wohnung zur disposition gestellt
wird wenn die kanzlerin allen ernstes
erklärt kinder sollten nur noch einen
freund treffen dürfen
liebe freunde haben wir denn die pest im
lande frau bundeskanzlerin
meine damen und herren
was ist eine pandemie von nationaler
tragweite
ja das definiert verfügt heute über den
ausnahmezustand
anscheinend ist herr drosten der
aktuelle deutsche souverän und die
argumente anderer virologen
epidemiologen die sich gegen die lok
down aussprechen werden beiseite
gewischt etwa das papier von herm strick
und der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung dass auch zahlreiche
erste verbände unterzeichnet haben
die unterzeichner fordern ein bundesweit
einheitliches ampelsystem anhand dessen
sich sowohl auf bundes als auch auf
kreisebene die aktuelle lage auf einen
blick erkennen lässt
sie setzen auf gebote anstelle von
verboten auf eigenverantwortung anstelle
von bevormundung
sie plädieren für die förderung von jene
konzepten anstelle von schließungen
sowie den schutz von risikogruppen durch
spezielle maßnahmen
wir unterstützen solche vernünftigen
ideen so wie wir uns den
wirtschaftlichen und
zwischenmenschlichen ruinösen
notstandsmaßnahmen widersetzen
wir werden noch viele monate mit dem
virus leben müssen und die bürger wissen
dass die meisten gehen
verantwortungsvoll mit der situation um
sowie wird so die beatles und die
konzertveranstalter verantwortungsvoll
mit der lage umgehen
sie haben sämtliche besucher registriert
sie haben ihre kapazitäten beschränkt
sie haben ihre konzepte entwickelt und
dafür bei sinkenden einnahmen geld
ausgegeben dass man sie trotzdem zu
schwert ist unerträglich und das läuft
ab diktatur hinaus
ich habe an dieser stelle schon gesagt
und ich wäre es nicht nur zu wiederholen
der souveränen dieses landes ist das
deutsche volk repräsentiert durch dieses
parlament nur dieses parlament von grund
kann grundrechts einschränkungen
beschließen
und zwar nach abwägung aller argumente
auf eine exakt begrenzte zeit nicht mal
das haben sie festgelegt ein exakt
begrenzte zeit meine damen und herren
dass die regierung die vom volk
gewählten abgeordneten vor vollendete
tatsachen stellt widerspricht dem geist
der demokratie und dem grundgesetz
allein deswegen lehnen wir dieses gesetz
ab und herr buschmann nicht weil wir
dieses parlament nicht wollen weil wir
die demokratie nicht wollen sondern weil
wir offensichtlich in diesem lande die
einzige demokratische fraktion sind
ich bedanke mich
hoffentlich haben auch die antwort was
gelernt
soweit also alexander gauland hier als
zweiter redner heftig umjubelt von
seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
bärbel bas spd ist die nächste rhetorik
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende unter anderem für
den bereich gesundheit bärbel bas für
die sozialdemokraten jetzt herr
präsident frau bundeskanzlerin meine
damen und herren kommen wir mal zurück
zu den fakten
wir haben in den letzten tagen alle sehr
viele zuschriften bekommen und sie
nehmen wir auch sehr ernst vielleicht
nicht an
vielleicht nicht alle vor allen dingen
nicht die die dieses gesetz mit 1933 und
einem ermächtigungsgesetz gleichsetzen
was den holocaust wirklich verharmlost
das muss ich hier an der stelle nochmal
zurückweisen und die befürchtungen die
befürchtungen dass wir für die
bundesregierung oder für einzelne
minister oder länderregierungen die
ermächtigung ausweiten genau das
gegenteil ist der fall mit diesem
entwurf und das muss man hier eine
stelle doch noch mal festhalten
ich will noch einmal deutlich machen wir
hatten bisher eine allgemeine
generalklausel auf der viele
verordnungen umgesetzt wurden und dass
wir diese jetzt präzisieren mit diesem
gesetzentwurf ist doch genau der punkt
dass wir eben einschränken dass wir
sagen wir beschriften wir müssen
begründen das ist doch der richtige
schritt dass wir wegkommen von dieser
generalklausel und die maßnahmen
definieren und schritt für schritt auch
sagen zu welchem punkt sie umgesetzt
werden dürfen so und das ist der ganz
entscheidende punkt den ich auch noch
mal sagen will
weil die befürchtungen die wenn viel
mehr mails bekommen haben
fest stand wir würden hier viel zu viel
ermächtigung an die länder geben das ist
nicht der fall
frau kollegin bars der kollege
schöneburg fdp würde gerne zwischen
vorgestellt nein im moment nicht
danke und ich will zu den fakten noch
mal kommen wir müssen im moment im
moment unsere kontakte reduzieren
natürlich kann man sich über jede
einzelne maßnahme streiten warum dieser
bereich geschlossen wird warum der warum
schulen auf bleiben da kann man sich
trefflich darüber streiten aber am ende
bleibt fakt wir müssen insgesamt die
kontakte reduzieren weil wir sonst die
drei probleme die wir im moment haben
nicht lösen können und darauf hat auch
die afg keine antwort ein problem ist
unsere labore weil wir sehr viel testen
und das ist gut und richtig
am limit sind deswegen haben wir in
diesem gesetz jetzt eine regelung drin
dass wir auch tiermedizinische und
zahnärztliche labore ausweiten
das ist genau der hintergrund das ist
deshalb auch wichtig im gesetz heute zu
entscheiden
der zweite punkt sind sie krankenhäuser
auch ein fakt den kann man nicht
wegdiskutieren
reden sie doch mit den kolleginnen
kollegen in den krankenhäusern arbeiten
mit dem patienten patienten und
angehörigen corona ist da es verursacht
starke schwere erkrankungen die bis zum
tod führen
und wir müssen die krankenhäuser jetzt
finanziell stützen und vor allen dingen
auch den gesundheitsschutz in der
abwägung aller anderen maßnahmen eben
auch berücksichtigen
das ist auch eine recht das im
grundgesetz verankert ist und natürlich
muss man das abwägen neben anderen
freiheitsrechten das tun wir hier aber
auch deswegen diskutieren wir dass sie
heute
und deswegen ist wichtig dass dieses
gesetz eben auch den teil beinhaltet
dass wir die krankenhäuser jetzt stärken
und übrigens wenn viele corona patienten
auf den intensivstationen sind und wir
andere operationen deshalb verschieben
müssen
ist das auch ein fakt den wir betrachten
müssen denn auch die menschen die auf
eine planbare operation warten
die haben auch den schutz verdient dass
wir die infektionszahlen insgesamt unter
damit auch sie wieder einen platz und
wer vielleicht notwendig wird nach einer
operation auf einer intensivstation
finden und der dritte fakt dass mal auch
eine positive botschaft wir bereiten uns
auf die impfungen vor
es gibt impfstoffe nicht nur ein
wahrscheinlich sogar mehrere
und ich möchte mal den aufschrei in der
bevölkerung hören wenn wir nicht jetzt
maßnahmen ergreifen würden uns darauf
vorzubereiten dass wir zentren haben
dass wir in stoffe einkaufen das wir
produzieren und alle die die an einen
anspruch haben auf eine info das ist
doch wichtig dass die menschen die
wollen noch geimpft werden können und
das hat nichts mit einer impfpflicht zu
tun sondern dass es auch ein grundrecht
dass man sagt dass es mal positiv
die entwicklung das ist in form übrigens
haben wir nach wie vor auch fortschritte
in der arzneimittel im
arzneimittelbereich jetzt werden im
moment arzneimittel auch auf den markt
kommen die schwere verläufe abmildern
können wir werden bei den tests besser
und insofern werden wir dann diese
einschränkende maßnahmen dean 28a
aufgelistet sind diese 17 maßnahmen so
in der abwägung am ende nicht mehr
brauchen wenn wir besser werden beim
schnell testen
wenn wir bei medikamenten arzneimitteln
und die impfstoffe haben das ist doch
die perspektive an der wir jetzt
arbeiten deshalb die kontakte jetzt
anstinken ein durchhalten um eben diese
maßnahmen dann auch durchzusetzen das
ist unser gemeinsames ziel und deshalb
kann die spd-fraktion diesem gesetz auch
guten gewissens zustimmen herzlichen
dank der § 28a enthält unter anderem die
grundrechts einschränkungen die
getroffen werden können
neu ist jetzt hier in der zweiten lesung
dass diese grundrechts einschränkungen
für vier wochen bestehen dürfen dann
muss neu beraten werden und nachher wird
der bundestag auch noch mal die
epidemische lage feststellen das ist
notwendig um überhaupt der exekutive
hier von seiten der legislative diese
möglichkeiten 1 1 christian lindner
jetzt der fdp fraktions und parteichef
und kollegen
wir beraten diesen gesetzentwurf im
zusammenhang mit konkreten maßnahmen
anfang november sind einschneidende
freiheits einschränkungen befristet für
diesen monat beschlossen worden wenige
tage im grunde stunden nachdem dieser
eigentlich befristeten massnahmen
beschlossen worden sind wurde bereits
aus der spitze der regierungskoalition
in frage gestellt auch diese befristung
tatsächlich bestand haben kam und am
montag dieser woche wollte das
bundeskanzleramt selbst noch zusätzliche
weitere freiheits einschränkungen ohne
dass die bisherigen
beschränkungen bei gastronomie kultur
sport und freizeiteinrichtungen konkret
analysiert worden wären
durch solche raschen veränderungen von
positionen einschätzungen und
ankündigungen stellt man das unverändert
große vertrauen der bevölkerung in die
politik unnötig auf die probe
unverändert fehlt eine dauerhaft durch
haltbare risikostrategie in den
beschlüssen von bund und ländern am
montag gibt es aber bereits eine
richtungsweisung wir haben bereits vor
monaten vorgeschlagen besonders von
gesundheitlichen risiken betroffenen ffp
zwei masken zur verfügung zu stellen wir
begrüßen dass die regierung diesen
schritt jetzt geht aber es müssten
konsequenter erfolgen
wir müssen die wunder werbenden gruppen
konsequent schützen denn das wäre ein
baustein um freiheit und
gesundheitsschutz besser
auszubalancieren als bisher
[Applaus]
das neue infektionsschutzgesetz leistet
zu einer durch haltbaren risikostrategie
leider nur wenige beiträge etwa mit
blick auf die test strategie oder die
digitalisierung
wir lehnen es aber insbesondere ab wegen
seines paragrafen 228 a
er ist im kern eine aufzählung von
freiheits einschränkungen diese
grundrechtseingriffe müssten nach dem
prinzip wenn dann klar einer konkret
definierten situation zugeordnet werden
nur dann können die menschen staatliches
handeln einschätzen
nur dann wissen auch landesregierungen
und kommunen welche maßnahme in welcher
lage zu ergreifen ist es ist ein
schweres versäumnis von union und spd
dass diese klare zuordnung unterlassen
wird wie notwendig wäre
hat sich am sonntag und montag gezeigt
bund und länder haben sich
beispielsweise über die frage der
halbierung des schulunterrichts zerlegt
in der sache die vom verfahren her war
das vorgehen des kanzleramts fragwürdig
wieder millionen familien im stich zu
lassen und gerade den schwächsten ihr
bürgerrecht auf bildung zu nehmen das
ist weder sinnvoll noch notwendig aber
vor allem aber vor allem hat sie am
montag gezeigt dass die gemeinsame
bewertungsgrundlage für die lage und
einverständnis über eine angemessene
reaktion fehlte wir das parlament können
in einer dynamischen lage nicht täglich
neu beurteilen
aber wir können und wir müssen die
entscheidungen der regierungen lenken
und ihnen klare leitplanken geben wenn
in grundrechte eingegriffen wird der
entwurf von union und spd gibt der
regierung aber keine leitplanken vor
sondern erstellt im gegenteil ein
freifahrschein aus und im übrigen auch
die alleinige orientierung an der zahl
von 50 infektionen 100.000 einwohner ist
willkürlich gegriffen
sie spiegelt nur die aktuelle
personalsituation der
gesundheitsbehörden auch andere
kriterien müssen berücksichtigt werden
um die pandemische lage einschätzen zu
können
insbesondere nach verfügbarkeit eines
impfstoffs und der impfung besonders
gefährdete personen wird sich auch die
bewertung der pandemie ändern
die praktische tauglichkeit ihres
gesetzesvorschlags hat deshalb eine viel
zu geringe halbwertszeit
zudem unterscheidet sich das von dem
geschehen regional in schleswig holstein
gibt es andere zahlen als in bayern
deshalb muss ein regional
differenziertes vorgehen weiter möglich
sein
es kann eine lage eintreten in der auch
empfindliche grundrecht
eingriffe nötig sind empfindlichere
sogar als im moment
es fehlt aber die möglichkeit dass sich
beispielsweise betriebe durch eine
behördlich genehmigte hygiene konzeption
von beschränkungen befreien können für
gastronomie und kultur wäre das eine
chance auf öffnung stattdessen gibt es
in der aufzählung von union und spd
sogar überflüssige maßnahmen wie alle
allgemeine ausgangssperre für menschen
von vor die tür treten geht aber kein
infektionsrisiko aushalten sie das enorm
text tatsächlich für erforderlich selbst
wenn es nur als ultima ratio gemeint ist
für uns der hausarrest für menschen
prinzipiell unverhältnismäßig und
deshalb sollte diese maßnahme gleich gar
nicht im gesetz erwähnt werden zu diesem
und zu diesem und zu anderen aspekten
haben wir ihnen konkrete vorschläge
unterbreitet es wäre im
allgemeininteresse wenn sich die
politische debatte schließlich auf
entscheidungen in der sache und nicht
schon auf die rechtsgrundlage
konzentrieren könnte im frühjahr hatte
sich die regierungskoalition noch um
gemeinsamkeiten mit der opposition
bemüht jetzt im herbst gab es nicht
einmal ein gesprächsangebot von union
und spd herr bringt haus das ist die
entscheidung des zuständigen
fachminister und der
regierungsfraktionen es gibt auch keine
verpflichtung für sie den austausch mit
der opposition zu suchen
aber die suche nach gemeinsamkeiten hier
im haus das wäre zugleich ein beitrag
zur befriedung eines gesellschaftlichen
konflikts gewesen
nächster redner ist der kollege jan
korte die linke landkarte ist der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
linksfraktion
sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst einmal
bevor ich zur kritik des gesetzes komme
will ich schon einmal eins deutlich
sagen das ist kein gesetz was in die
diktatur führt und wer das behauptet
verhöhnt die opfer von diktaturen die
gefoltert der knechte und ermordet
wurden halten darf man nicht an meine
damen und herren nun zum gesetz was wir
ablehnen werden denn ich will das noch
mal deutlich sagen diese bundesregierung
hat den sommer verpennt sie hätte zeit
gehabt ihr analyse vorzulegen das hat
sie nicht getan
und ja das verfahren kollege gross im
römer ist zulässig
politisch klug ist es in diesen zeiten
nicht und der bundestag ist frau
bundeskanzlerin kein bremsklotz dem er
mal hier nach gutdünken mal mit
anwesenheit beglücken kann oder nicht
sondern eher zentral für die
meinungsfindung und für die
nachvollziehbarkeit der pandemie
bekämpfung liebe kollege und kollegen es
klar zu sagen denn die überwältigende
mehrheit
der menschen zeigt die ein solidarisches
grund verhalten jeden tag jedes
wochenende und ohne die wird es nicht
laufen und deswegen finde ich eine
gewisse und wenn man so will
fast schon monarchische züge nach den mp
kassiert also verkündet was jetzt
passiert das ist der sache nicht
angemessen und damit verspielt man
akzeptanz liebe kollegen gelegt ja in
der tat es gibt gute verbesserungen die
sie vorgelegt haben beispielsweise dass
die gästelisten aus restaurants
natürlich nur zur bekämpfung der
pandemie nutzbar gemacht werden dürfen
dass es richtig dass mehr begründung
eingefordert wird es richtig und auch
das bundeseinheitliche regelung
angestrebt werden ist richtig aber ich
will es auf einen punkt bringen warum an
diesem gesetz nicht zustimmen kann
nämlich sie will ich ganz deutlich sagen
jeder eingriff in die grund und
freiheitsrechte die so bitter erkämpft
worden sind die so unser fundament ist
dass uns hier streiten können bedarf der
debatte und zustimmung oder ablehnung
des bundestages und genau das ist nicht
vorgesehen
deswegen kann man den nicht richtig wir
verlegen
und das ist auch eine
demokratische grundsatzfrage das
natürlich eben nicht in einer demokratie
niemals regierungen über solche massiven
eingriffe in die grund und
freiheitsrechte entscheiden dürfen das
ist nicht zuletzt das muss hier
geschehen wenn überhaupt und wenn es
notwendig ist liebe kollegen überlegen
denn das will ich schon sagen sie kennen
den braten sie können auch die aktuellen
1 brachten die akzeptanz sinkt und
deswegen ist es völlig entscheiden und
darauf will ich warnen diese
schreckliche corona krise die schon so
viele tote gefordert hat müssen wir
aufpassen dass sie nicht zu einer
schleichenden demokratiekrise wird liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dann hätten wir
ein doppeltes problem und deswegen ist
es entscheidend das ist ja auch in der
logik sonst verstehen die leute das doch
auch nicht wir brauchen bei allen
maßnahmen und auch bei den runden
ministerpräsidenten vorher hier eine
debatte auch durch die bundeskanzlerin
was die deutsche handel und was ihre
linie ist nur so geht es danach wieder
vorbei zu kommen und dass man mit zuteil
das kann er nicht
ernst zu sein so geht es auf jeden fall
nicht jetzt wollen das sagen was bewegt
eigentlich die menschen mit denen
spricht wenn wir morgens oxseed ag
tucker mit den eltern und so weiter und
so fort was belegt wie ich die leute
bewegen tut die leute vor allem ob die
maßnahmen die in weiten teilen natürlich
auch richtig sind eigentlich frau sibel
sind und nicht plausibles folgendes es
wird auf der einen seite kontakt
beschränkung gefordert und wir
durchgesetzt und gleichzeitig gibt es
allen ernstes verkaufsoffene sonntage
das versteht doch wirklich kein mensch
mehr daraus kinder sollen sollen nur
noch so die empfehlung einen freund
treffen mal gucken wie das überhaupt
möglich ist umzusetzen und gleichzeitig
sehen die leute dass die kinder mit 30
kinder zusammen in der golfschule
morgens sitzen das ist doch nicht
logisch liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
oder auch nicht starten wird
dass man neun milliarden euro hier umzug
für die lufthansa zur verfügung stellt
aber 0 milliarden euro für ein
bundesweites luftfilter programm für die
schulklassen das versteht kein mensch
viele kollegen verlegt und ich will auch
eintrag ein zielen muss in den nächsten
tagen doch sein dass jeder schüler jeder
lehrer jede pflegekraft so schnell ein
test bekommt und ein testergebnis wie
jeder bundesligaspieler das müssten ihre
aufgabe in dieser woche seinen kollegen
und ich möchte noch einer
in diesem wirklich schwierigen und auch
schlimmen zeiten die uns ja auch sorgen
machen wo man mit den leuten spricht die
viel angst haben wie das weitergeht wo
leute von ihrem wenigen urlaub
freiwillig urlaub nehmen um eine woche
in quarantäne zu gehen damit sie ihre
eltern und großeltern treffen dürfen da
muss man ja mal daran erinnern was leute
hier auf sich nehmen das war sie völlig
verpennt haben um das deutlich zu sagen
ist und das wäre verantwortungsvoll
gewesen eine zukunfts kitze eine
perspektive für die zeit nach der
pandemie hier einmal vorzustellen
der staat ist schon aus dem letzten loch
vor der anlieferung haseloff in sachsen
anhalt gab es schon vor der pandemie
2000 lehrer zu wenig schon vor der
pandemie und jetzt wäre es doch mal eine
zusage endlich umgehend die
kommerzialisierung des gesundheitswesens
zu beenden umgehen
eine erste partie sierung der
krankenhäuser anzugehen die marktlogik
muss raus aus unserer gesellschaft liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und ich will
auch eines sagen wenn man mit den leuten
spricht fragen sie natürlich auch in den
gesprächen wer bezahlt das alles das ist
eine berechtigte frage
und in der regel gegen es so wenn man
fragt was denkt ihr denn wer das bezahlt
da kommt die mittlerweile resignierte
antwort das wird so sein wie immer wir
kleinen leute werden das bezahlen und
deswegen wäre es ein richtiges zeichen
hier im bundestag endlich für die
milliardäre in diesem land eine
vermögensabgabe zu beschließen dass es
nicht so läuft wie immer
und kollegen unsere versprechen
abzugeben dass nach der bundestagswahl
nach der pandemie der sozialstaat nicht
weiter abgerissen wird sondern im
gegenteil dass er gestärkt wird weil er
menschen sicherheit gibt und wenn man
das beherzigen würde dann hätte man
größere akzeptanz dann würde man die
leute einladen für eine bessere zukunft
mitzumachen bei der bekämpfung der
pandemie und dann hätte man eine chance
auf eine solidarischere eine gerechtere
und eine viel lebenswertere gesellschaft
nach der pandemie vielleicht könnte man
so eine neue zeit des gemeinsam
hinbekommen das wäre angemacht vielen
dank die antwort hat noch mal klar
gemacht wo die probleme der aus sicht
der linksfraktion liegen unter anderem
fordern die linken das bei jedem
grundrechts 1
bei jedem grundrechtseingriff der
deutsche bundestag befasst werden muss
der aktuelle gesetzentwurf sieht das ja
nicht vor sondern sieht im artikel 28
jahre vor das konto jetzt einsätze
möglich sind für vier wochen im ermessen
der exekutive manuela rottmann jetzt
wird müssen 90 die grünen sich die opfer
im ausschuss für recht und
verbraucherschutz
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
wir schaffen heute für notwendige
eingriffe in die grundrechte einen
gesetzlichen rahmen
wir definieren den zweck der maßnahmen
dass der zweck ist die sicherung der
funktionsfähigkeit unseres
gesundheitswesens
daran können und daran werden die
gerichte in zukunft die geeignetheit die
erforderlichkeit und die verhältnisse
sich kite der rechtsverordnungen der
länder messen wir verpflichten die
länder dazu ihre rechtsverordnung zu
begründen und wir befristen die geltung
auch vier wochen
für untersagen von versammlungen und
religiösen zusammenkünften für besuchs
beschränken und den alten und
pflegeheimen krankenhäusern gelten in
zukunft erhöhte voraussetzungen unter
allen umständen muss in zukunft ein
minimum an sozialen kontakten gewahrt
bleiben der besondere verfassungstreue
von kunst und kultur wird anerkannt
kontaktdaten dürfen nur noch zur
nachverfolgung von infektionsketten
verarbeitet und weitergegeben werden
eine eindeutige loest es festgelegt die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite wird gesetzlich definiert wir
legen damit heute die grundlage dafür
dass gut begründete evidenzbasierte
maßnahmen auch eine gerichtlichen
kontrolle standhalten und das schult
denjenigen die jetzt auf den
intensivstationen und in den
gesundheitsämtern mit dieser zweiten
infektionswelle kämpfen und wir schulden
es ihnen heute sind wir unserem
glücklich mit diesem gesetzentwurf nein
das sind wir nicht ein schönheitspreis
wird er nicht gewinnen
es wäre gut gewesen schon in diesem
gesetz für bürgerinnen und bürger klar
erkennbar zu machen dass ich doch auch
unsere abwägung geändert haben seit märz
und april
wir sind uns doch hier vielfach alich
ministerpräsidenten stimmen uns dazu
hier im haus stimmen uns viele zu dass
zum beispiel das kindeswohl einen viel
höheren stellenwert in der abwägung
haben heißt das hatten wir ein schreiben
können kinder und jugendliche brauchen
den kontakt zu anderen kindern und
kontakten reisebeschränkungen müssen
natürlich respektieren dass familie
partnerschaft und ehe geschützt sind
bei der untersuchung von konzerten
müssen wir andere abwägung treffen als
bei der absage eines kochkurses und die
sogenannte arbeits quarantäne mit der
ausländische saisonkräfte trotz
infektion weiter ausgebeutet werden muss
beendet werden
die grünen wollen mehr als das was in
diesem gesetz steht wir wollen eine
umfassendere berichtspflicht der
bundesregierung und wir sind immer noch
davon überzeugt einen pandemie rad
können wir all diese fragen was ist der
richtige maßstab um instanzen zu
ergänzen
die können wir vernünftig mit diversen
sachverstand diskutieren und damit diese
gesetzliche grundlage auch verbessern
wir bitten sie deswegen
um unterstützung für unseren
änderungsantrag ich halte diesen
änderungsantrag auch im bundesrat für
zuständen zustimmungsfähig der
gesetzentwurf der koalition kann für uns
nur ein anfang sei vielleicht ist es in
teilen sogar auch nur ein provisorium
die gerichte werden uns weitere hinweise
geben wir müssen die frage der
entschädigung anpacken da beißt die maus
keinen faden ab wir müssen sie
gesetzlich regeln
herr korte einen eigenen vorschlag der
linken sehe ich sie sagen die
bundesregierung seit sommer seit sommer
hätte die bundesregierung hätte hätte
hätte der leiter der staatskanzlei
dringend benjamin hoff hat ein sehr
schönes video ins internet gestellt in
dem er begründet warum er nachher im
bundesrat diesen gesetzentwurf zustimmt
den laden hält man so nicht zusammen
die spd fdp bündnis noch da
ausnahmsweise die fdp gewinnt diese oft
diese oft im preis für schönen schein
heute ihr gestern abend verschickte
gesetzentwurf ist von der
regelungstechnik daher tatsächlich
deutlich besser als der
regierungsentwurf er ist deutlich besser
sogar verdächtig stark einem entwurf den
ich in meiner schublade habe über
manches musste man streiten
dass die schließung von schulen
einfacher möglich sein soll als die
schließung von betrieben überzeugt mich
nicht
und bei dem komplexen thema der
entschädigung sind sie eben nicht ganz
präzise sondern ziemlich grob und
ziemlich schlampig aber die details mal
weggelassen das hätte eine gute
diskussionsgrundlage sein können krise
bewertet man aber nicht nur schön
anträgen
ich habe in der letzten woche mehr als
mir lieb und mehr als der koalition
liegt ist mit den telefoniert ich bin
hinterher gelaufen und ich sehe deswegen
wesentliche verbesserungen in den
geänderten gesetzentwurf der auch mit
den ländern abgestimmt ist
sie haben offenbar kein einziges mal
irgendwo angerufen sie haben nicht
versucht diesen gesetzgebungsprozess zu
beeinflussen und im ausschuss am runter
habe ich von ihnen nur die klage darüber
gehört wie kurz die beratungskosten ist
die beratungs frist für ihren antrag die
ist nun weil sie ihn gestern haben das
verschickt haben
ganz genau
wer heute über verfassung sie wissen
ganz genau dass das gesetz
zustimmungspflichtig ist und dass nicht
ein neustart ihres antrags nicht ein
buchstabe stimmt ist mit den
bundesländern insbesondere die
unbestimmte entschädigungsregelung die
und kalkulierte risiken auch die länder
verschiebt sie wissen dass das auch ihre
landesregierung nicht mittragen werden
nicht diese woche und auch nicht nächste
woche und wenn es anders ist dann
bringen sie mir die unterschrift ihres
generalsekretärs unter diesem
gesetzentwurf
sie stellen als ein antrag von dem sie
wissen dass er jetzt nicht
zustimmungsfähig ist im bundesrat das
sieht man auf den ersten blick gut aus
in wahrheit ist es die alte haltung der
fdp lieber nicht lieber kein problem
lösen
vielen dank manuela rottmann
hat sich viel vorgenommen aber sie hat
noch mal dargestellt wie sind versucht
hat die opposition einzuarbeiten die
grünen werden wohl für das gesetz
stimmen wenngleich sie selber einige
veränderungen fordern in ihrem
änderungsantrag der nächste redner ist
insofern spannend als dass er vielleicht
der mächtigste minister war die in
deutschland die hatte jens spahn der
bundesgesundheitsminister er ist ja
durch diese gesetze ermächtigt dinge zu
tun die vorher undenkbar waren eben
grundrechts einschnitte
diese pandemie ist ein
jahrhundertereignis
herr bundesminister darf sich einen
moment unterbrechen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen im
parlament tragen wir unterschiedliche
meinungen mit argumenten aus
die mögen gut oder schlecht zeigt aber
wir tragen sie nicht mit transparenten
und ähnlichen dingen aus und deswegen
ist meine dringende bitte aber es ist
jetzt eine billig kann es aber auch
gleich so entscheiden bitte tun sie
diese schilder oder plakate sowas immer
ist unverzüglich mit der entfernen
wenn sie sie nicht entfernen muss ich
sie zur ordnung gerufen also bitte nehmt
sie sie weg die fdp fraktion mit einer
demonstration die im deutschen bundestag
verboten ist
[Musik]
die plakate und das wort hat der mond
bundesminister jens spahn
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen diese pandemie ist ein
jahrhundertereignis ein naturereignis
jahr gleichsam eine naturkatastrophe sie
ist eine zumutung und eine
bewährungsprobe
die schicksalhaft über uns gekommen in
unserer modernen komplexen zeit und in
dieser jahrhundert pandemie ist klar
egal was wir tun oder ob wir nichts tun
es entsteht schaden egal was wir
entscheiden ob wir gar nicht entscheiden
es entsteht schaden die frage ist wo
entsteht welcher schaden es geht um
wirtschaftlichen schaden für viele
einzelne bürgerinnen und bürger und für
die volkswirtschaft
es geht um sozialen schaden menschliche
herten und ausnahmesituationen es geht
um gesundheitlichen schaden leid und tod
wir müssen nun gewichten prioritäten
setzen
mehr welches minister gestanden sie eine
zwischenfrage abgeordneten ein herr
präsident ich möchte meine rede jetzt
gerne gesehen die versammlungen halten
wir müssen nun gewichten prioritäten
setzen abwägen und tun dies seit beginn
der pandemie
die wissenschaft kann uns beraten die
fakten und einschätzungen aber kein
biologe kann infektiologe kein
mikrobiologe kein professor drosten und
auch kein professor back die kann uns
diese aufgabe abnehmen diese
entscheidungen zu treffen wir im
deutschen
wir im deutschen bundestag und in der
von ihm legitimierten regierungen wir
müssen gewichten welchen schaden wer wo
wie ertragen wollen und ertragen können
der schutz der gesundheit der steht
dabei nicht absolut ja er ist abzuwägen
mit anderen grundrechten aber die
körperliche unversehrtheit steht
übrigens auch in dem grundgesetz dass
sie gerade hoch gehalten hat ist ihnen
das leid davon habe ich gar nichts
gehört und ist ihnen das leid auf den
intensivstationen in den krankenhäusern
in den familien diejenigen die
langzeitschäden haben ist ihnen dieses
leid egal
das ist doch die frage die sich stellt
der schutz der gesundheit steht nicht
absolut aber wir haben entschieden dass
der schutz der gesundheit in dieser
pandemie ein relativ stärkeres gewicht
bekommt wir haben uns entschieden in
großer mehrheit entschieden in der
gesellschaft
und hier im parlament dass wir keine
überforderung unseres gesundheitssystems
akzeptieren wollen dass wir leid durch
krankheit intensiv medizin beatmung und
tod zwar nicht absolut vermeiden können
wir dieses leid aber bestmöglich
reduzieren wollen steigende
infektionszahlen an dieser praktischen
erkenntnis führt auch die spannendste
theoretische debatte nicht vorbei
steigende infektionszahlen führen in
unseren eltern dem land bei den
eigenschaften dieses virus früher oder
später zu steigendem leid auf unseren
intensivstationen und zum
kontrollverlust bei exponentiellen
wachstum im und um das zu vermeiden
müssen die infektionszahlen runter und
vor allem müssen sie in ihrer
entwicklung unter kontrolle bleiben ja
wir haben mit den aktuellen maßnahmen
tritt gefasst wir haben das
exponentielle wachstum gestoppt aber wir
sind noch nicht überm berg und als
bundesminister für gesundheit sage ich
ihnen dass sich diese gewichtung diese
starke ausrichtung auf bestmöglichen
gesundheitsschutz in dieser pandemie
weiterhin richtig finde
dabei nichts absolut gelten kann auch
nicht der schutz der gesundheit geht es
um die richtige balance das richtige
austariert und diese balance bringen wir
doch alle jeden tag jeder in seinem
alltag
wir als gesellschaft und wir in der
politischen vertretung und führung
dieses landes
es geht darum wirtschaftliche härten
abzufedern und erträglich zu machen
durch hilfe unterstützung
konjunkturpakete und es geht darum jeden
tag mehr und besser dieses virus
beherrschen zu können
durch die aha regeln durch das
reduzieren von kontakten durch neue mehr
testmöglichkeiten und immer bessere
schutzkonzepte durch neue und bessere
medikamente und ja als entscheidenden
schritt zur tatsächlichen kontrolle über
dieses virus vor allem auch durch
schimpfen und weil es ja schon wieder
anders behauptet wird auch in den
sozialen medien ich gebe ihnen mein wort
es wird in dieser pandemie keine
impfpflicht geben hören sie endlich auf
anderes zu behaupten
und gleichzeitig macht es doch mut es
gibt zuversicht ist es licht am ende des
tunnels dass wir in diesen dunklen
novembertagen ernsthaft damit rechnen
können dass es so schnell ein impfstoff
geben wird wie nie zuvor in der
geschichte der menschheit impfen ist
eine der größten errungenschaften der
menschheit menschen vermeidet jeden tag
unzählige slide und krankheit impfen ist
fortschritt im besten sinne und es macht
mich ein stück stolz dass der erste
impfstoff der wirksamkeit zeigt aus
deutschland kommt und hier entwickelt
worden jetzt liebe kollegen die kollegen
wir sind meine damen und herren bis
hierhin gut durch diese krise gekommen
vergleichsweise auch mit der situation
in anderen ländern auch in dieser
zweiten welle und ich frage mich
manchmal schon in welchem anderen land
wären sie eigentlich lieber keines
unserer nachbarländer hat mit milderen
mitteln diese pandemie unter kontrolle
bekommen wo wären sie eigentlich lieber
in der bundesrepublik deutschland das
wirklich machen wir schon interessiert
und dass das zunächst dass wir so
vergleichsweise gut durch diese pandemie
auch in dieser zweiten welle bis hierhin
gekommen sind
das ist vor allem so war die
allermeisten bürgerinnen und bürger auf
sich und ihre mitmenschen achten und zu
schützen
und es ist so weil die große mehrheit
der deutschen unsere politik mitträgt
und ja nicht wenige zweifeln haben
sorgen oder bedenken und doch tragen
auch sie in großer mehrheit den
grundsätzlichen ansatz unserer politik
und die entscheidung mit und ja laut
sein
dagegen seien sogar das offensichtliche
leugnen
all das ist möglich und muss möglich
sein in einem freien offenen land aber
wer laut ist ist deswegen noch lange
nicht im recht und schon gar nicht nur
wegen seiner lautstärke in der mehrheit
debatte ist möglich
debatte ist nötig kontroverse ist nötig
aber doch nicht unerbittlich und voller
härte sondern so dass wir
zusammenbleiben zusammenhalt ist das was
dieses land am meisten braucht in dieser
pandemie und ihre rede jedenfalls war
kein beitrag zum zusammenhalt in diesem
landtag fordert der präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir wollen
weiter gut durch diese krise kommen
dafür müssen wir uns immer wieder der
lage anpassen das virus ist dynamisch
wir müssen es auch sein daher nun das
dritte bevölkerungsschutz gesetz in neun
monaten
das uns in dynamischer lage die
rechtliche grundlage gibt mit diesem
virus noch besser umzugehen wie als
bundesregierung und die landesregierung
wir brauchen in dieser pandemie die
befugnisse und instrumente zu handeln
und zu entscheiden
zum schutz und symbole unserer
bürgerinnen und bürger und diese
befugnisse und diese instrumente die
kann uns nur von dem vom deutschen volk
gewählten bundestag gegeben werden und
darum bitten wir sie heute jeden sparen
der noch mal gesagt hat wie gewicht
wichtig die gesundheit von anderen
menschen auch ist als
gesundheitsminister ist es ehrenhaft
aber er hat auch betonte dass die
freiheitsrechte und die und dede recht
auf gesundheit natürlich divergieren
sind jetzt kurzintervention seit einigen
wochen notiert habe die bundesregierung
gefragt welche maßnahmen sie denn
ergreift um unsere mitbürger vor diese
mutierten virus zu schützen
die antwort war sie tut nichts keine
grenzkontrollen keine flächendeckenden
gesundheitstests für einreisende aus
dänemark es gibt keine speziellen
massnahmen zum schutz der bevölkerung
vor dem mutierten virus auf der anderen
seite will man hier nun im eilverfahren
ein gesetz durchpeitschen mitnehmen
nahezu alle grundrechte ausgehebelt und
die grundlage für staatliche willkür und
kontrolle festgeschrieben werden
wie willkürlich gehandelt wird können
konnten wir ja in bayern bereits letzte
woche sehen wo es ein gerichtsurteil
gehabt dass fitnessstudios geöffnet
werden dürfen und daraufhin dann die
bayerische staatsregierung hingegangen
ist und gesagt hat dann machen wir ein
komplettes verbot für
der sport meine frage an der stelle ist
wie kann es sein dass unter dem vorwand
des schutzes der bevölkerung massive
grundrechts einschränkungen beschlossen
werden sollen während die
bundesregierung nichts unternimmt um die
deutschen bürger vor dem mutierten virus
aus dänemark zu schützen und müsste man
wenn es wirklich um den schutz der
menschen ginge und wenn wie sie herr
spahn gesagt haben das virus ist
dynamisch wir müssen es auch sein müsste
man dann nicht mit den vorhandenen
mitteln erstmal realen gefahren wie
mutationen des virus begegnen anstatt
sich mit massiven grundrechtseingriff
selbst zu ermächtigen
herr bundesminister wenn sie mögen haben
sich das wort zu begegnung
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir sind im engen austausch mit
dänemark waren ist von der ersten stunde
an als es entsprechende meldung gab das
friedrich-loeffler-institut genauso für
die veterinärmedizin wie unsere behörden
im bundesministerium für gesundheit wir
sind im europäischen austausch zu dieser
frage wir sind nur wir machen nur einen
unterschied
wir treffen entscheidungen auf basis von
fakten und alles was wir bis jetzt im
austausch mit den dänischen kolleginnen
und kollegen im engen austausch auf
wissenschaftlicher basis an
erkenntnissen haben gibt es viele
spekulationen aber überhaupt keine
erkenntnisse zu dem was sie gerade
unterstellt haben und solange wir keine
fakten haben um keine evidenz ergreifen
wir nicht um irgendwelche maßnahmen zu
ergreifen maßnahmen das ist der
unterschied zwischen ihnen und uns und
zum zweiten
machen sie uns auch ein wenig doch die
argumentation ihres eigenen
fraktionsvorsitzenden hinfällig entweder
ist dieses virus wie dargestellt nicht
weiter schlimm und braucht keine
maßnahmen oder aber wir müssen schon bei
dem leisesten verdacht selbst ohne
wissenschaftliche basis maßnahmen
ergreifen beides zusammen geben weil das
geht nicht und deswegen
ihnen geht es am ende immer nur um eins
egal ob so oder so rum
hauptsache krawall und wir schützen der
wein unsere bürgerinnen und bürger haft
nächste klare ansage des
bundesgesundheitsministers hier richtung
haben sich von der af die nächste
rednerin hier in der debatte ist
christine aschenberg-dugnus sie ist die
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der fdp
fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
kollege in den kollegen lieber herr
minister spanier wir müssen hier in der
pandemie entscheidungen treffen aber die
entscheidung würden wir gerne hier im
parlament treffen denn ein minister oder
eine regierung sind nun mal nicht die
besseren gesetzgeber die debatten
darüber gehören hier in die parlamente
und treffen der bürgerinnen und bürger
auch abgebildet werden
wenn direkt wir haben in unserem
umfangreichen änderungsantrag schlagen
wir vor wenn die regierung bundesweite
maßnahmen der länder herbeiführen möchte
ist sie verpflichtet vorher die
zustimmung des deutschen bundestages
einzuholen
das ist die richtige maßnahme denn damit
hätten wir solche peinlichen solches
peinliche hinterzimmer chaos sie war es
in den letzten wochen erleben hätten wir
dann nicht mehr nötig meine damen und
herren ihr gesetz ist handwerklich
schlecht gemacht ihrem gesetz fehlt die
rechtsstaatliche bestimmtheit sie haben
einfach einen unbestimmten rechtsbegriff
gegen einen anderen unbestimmten
rechtsbegriff ausgetauscht es bleibt
völlig unklar welche
freiheitseinschränkung in welcher lage
angemessen sind wir und deswegen so
betone ich das immer wir haben konkrete
maßnahmen vorgeschlagen
da schlagen wir ein abgestuftes konzept
von maßnahmen vor die sich am jeweiligen
infektionsgeschehen orientieren
tatbestand rechtsfolge so macht man das
das ist klar das ist nachvollziehbar
meine damen und herren
so weiß man in jeder situation mit
welcher maßnahme zu rechnen ist wie
erhalten pauschale schließungen für
falsch bei uns ist es so wenn sie mit
einem anerkannten hygiene konzept kommen
und ein infektionsrisiko
unwahrscheinlich ist dann können sie
kultureinrichtungen weiter öffnen dann
kann die gastronomie geöffnet werden
dann die hotellerie
nichts ist ungerechter als pauschale
schließungen meine damen und herren
außerdem haben wir ist ihre definition
einer epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite für uns zu weit gefasst
außerdem wollen wir dass die
feststellung der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite
nach zwei monaten automatisch ändert
auch das haben wir beantragt meine damen
und herren unsere änderungsantrag ist
der goldstandard das wurde von frau
rottmann ja auch schon festgestellt das
kann man von ihrem gesetz nicht sagen
vielen dank
nächste redner indische kollege drv
gebet wie frauke petry ehemalige fdp
chefin und jetzt eine von sechs
fraktionslosen abgeordneten ein pardon
ich muss sagen 5 marco bülow ist ja
gestern oder vorgestern eingetreten in
die spaßpartei die partei der
gesetzentwurf der großen position ist
immerhin der dritte innerhalb von acht
monaten und weiß immer noch gravierende
mängel auf
sie erklären sich als vertreter des
parlaments für das krisenthema krone
genaugenommen für mich bin zuständig für
dessen dirigieren sie die verantwortung
dafür ein regierung und behörden
das ist mit blick auf die zum teil
gravierenden grundrechtseingriff jungen
bis hin zur frage der unverletzlichkeit
der wohnung ein ausweis von
erschreckender feigheit parlamentarier
haben sich persönlich immer
verantwortung zu stellen und selbiges
die übernehmen
ausgerechnet die neue virtuelle
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist
verfassungsrechtlich nicht existent soll
ich sagen
illegal und hat zudem gerade ihre
handlungsunfähigkeit bewiesen aber sie
liebe koalitionen beauftragen genau
diese runde mit dem regieren auf dem
verordnungsweg sie schaffen mit koch
institut erneut doppelstruktur zur
datenerhebungen können wieder einmal der
sammelwut nicht widerstehen
die versprochene anonymität der daten
der stets geforderte datenschutz wird so
ad absurdum geführt weil sich die person
hinter vielen einzelnen daten
puzzleteilen problemlos identifizieren
lässt in ihrem gesetz wird ist von
unbestimmten bewertungsmaßstäben ob sie
von einer bedrohlichen krankheit reden
so als ob es ihr um gefühlte kategorien
gehen darf oder ein
instanz wert von 50 positiven pcr-test
pro woche festlegen weder das eine noch
das andere wird der höhere für
grundrechts einschränkungen gerecht sie
kümmern sich also weder um ein halbwegs
gutes gesetz noch um die folgen in
zahlreichen wirtschaftszweigen
wer so die grundlage unserer
werteordnung einiger von der damen und
herren muss die sprechblase von der
liberalen demokratie bitteschön nie mehr
in den eigenen mund nehmen und dann noch
eins wir freuen uns alle in diesem haus
auf hoffentlich sind sichere impfungen
für alle die sich impfen lassen wollen
wenn das aber so ist was ist ihr
gesetzentwurf von heute dann überhaupt
noch wert dann sind alle grund ist ein
streng und diese hier heute beschlossen
sehen wollen überhaupt und gar nicht
mehr verhältnismäßig und auf dem
rechtsweg problemlos angreifbar was für
eine verschwendung von parlaments zeit
und steuergeldern meine damen und herren
was sie heute beschließen ist eine
entmündigung sets das ist als signal des
parlaments schon schlimm genug aber dass
sie ohne jeglichen schaden
die bürger auch noch zu
betreuungsbedürftigen kindern
degradieren das ist skandalös frau
konnte sich zu wehren ist geradezu einen
demokratischen bürgerpflicht herzlichen
dank frauke petry eine von sechs
fraktionslosen abgeordneten marco bülow
es war jetzt mitglied der partei und
damit der erste abgeordnete der partei
im deutschen bundestag aber als einziger
abgeordneter kann natürlich keine
fraktion seien insofern bleibt es bei
sechs fraktionslosen abgeordneten
so und jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
rechtspolitischen sprecher johannes
fechner der spd
[Applaus]
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauern die
lage ist dramatisch die infektionszahlen
steigen deutlich und vor allem immer
mehr menschen erkranken schwer an corona
und genau in dieser dramatischen lage
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass wir corona
effektiv bekämpfen und dazu gehört dass
wir die maßnahmen auf sichere
rechtsgrundlage stellen dass wir die
bürgerrechte der bürgerinnen und bürger
schützen und dass wir starke parlamente
haben nach wie vor auch in der korona
krise liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wenn jetzt ernsthaft behauptet wird
dass dieses gesetz wie das
ermächtigungsgesetz der nazis wirken
würde dann sage ich das ist vollkommen
absurd das ermächtigungsgesetz der nazis
war der auftakt für die nazi barbarei
die millionen menschen in deutschland
und in europa das leben gekostet hat wir
machen genau das gegenteil wir schützen
die gesundheit wir schützen das leben
unserer bürgerinnen und bürger liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen insbesondere
unseren änderungsantrag kann man guten
gewissens als regierungs begrenzungs
gesetz bezeichnen denn wir verringern
die befugnisse der bundesregierung im
bund und land wir streichen zum beispiel
die viel zu weitgehende befugnisse
werden unser kollege fechner
ich habe zwei wünsche für zwischenfragen
einmal kollegen gürtel und einmal vor
kollegen dr schienenprojekt gestattet
sie die fragen nein die debatte hat ein
hohes niveau deswegen möchte ich jetzt
keine zwischenfragen von der alb
die bundesregierung muss uns zukünftige
über die aktuelle lage berichten und die
landesregierung dürfen die
schutzmaßnahme nur dann treffen wenn wir
als parlament die epidemische lage
beschlossen haben uns nur dann wenn wir
wie wir hier im parlament vorgegeben
haben die voraussetzungen nämlich
bestimmte infektionszahlen erfüllt sind
also wir haben als parlament klare
leitplanken für die schutzmaßnahmen hier
vorgegeben und wir haben eine doppelte
befristung für die schutzmaßnahmen
die maßnahmen können von den ländern nur
solange ergriffen werden wie die
epidemische lage gilt und die länder
müssen sie befristen auf vier wochen
grundsätzlich und müssen sie auch
begründen auch das ist eine ganz
wichtige maßnahmen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und ganz entscheidend ist dass wir auch
in der korona krise die grundrechte der
bürger waren und auch dem dient dieses
gesetz ja zum schutz der bürger vor
krone sind grundrechtseingriffe
erforderlich etwa durch hygiene konzepte
oder abstands maßnahmen das fordern ja
übrigens auch die oppositionsanträge von
grüne und afd
aber genau deshalb befristet mir die
maßnahmen weil das legitimationsdruck
schafft und so von den landesregierungen
immer wieder überprüft werden muss ob
eine maßnahme noch notwendig ist und ob
er sie tatsächlich noch brauchen oder ob
sie eben zu sehr in die grundrechte der
bürger eingreift unter schaffen
insbesondere für den grundrechts
relevanten bereich für versammlungen für
gottesdienste für ausgangs
beschränkungen oder bei besuchsverbot
deutlich höhere hürden für die eingriffe
dass das eben verhindert wird weil er
eben nicht ein kollege fechner ich habe
sie richtig verstanden dass sie keine
zwischenfragen zu lassen wollen
die frau rottmann hat so gut
mitgearbeitet bei dem gesetzt sie darf
es fragen also also jetzt doch dann muss
ich sie in zukunft wieder fragen ob sie
zwischen zwei zugelassen frau kollegin
rund montieren
vielen dank
lieber herr fälle dass die frage zu
lassen
ich habe gerade eine nachricht erhalten
von der sachverständigen andrea kießling
hierfür die spd viel gearbeitet hat die
wir genannt hatten als an zu hören dass
sachverständigen der anhörung des
gesundheitsausschusses und frau kießling
hat mich eigentlich gebeten herrn
bauland etwas auszurichten nämlich dass
sie sich verbittert von ihm hier ihre
führen zitiert zu werden weil die
aussage mit der sie zitiert worden ist
sich ausdrücklich auf den ursprünglichen
gesetzentwurf bezieht und nicht auf den
gesetzentwurf der hier heute zur debatte
steht stimmen sie mir zu herr fechner
dass das ein ganz typischer umgang der
afg mit wahrheit und mit dem
verfassungsrecht ist
andrea dies wegen des gewichtigen
verfassungsexperte in der bochumer
ruhr-uni und war eine der
sachverständigen die haben donnerstag
kritik an dem gesetz biete im nachhinein
aber die nachbesserung sehr lobte ganz
zu und wird es zur gelegenheit nehmen
noch mal ausdrücklich darauf zu
verweisen dass wir diesen
gesetzesentwurf eng mit der wissenschaft
beraten haben mit der von ihnen
genannten sachverständigen aber auch
denjenigen die in der anhörung anwesend
war und insbesondere zu den änderungen
da hören wir durchaus auch lob und
deswegen danke ich ihnen für ihre
zwischenfrage ich stimme ihnen auch in
der beurteilung zu
das ist der afg halt einmal mehr darauf
ankommt lieber die menschen aufzuhetzen
anstatt hier sacharbeit für die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger zu
machen
ich komme zurück an vielen stellen
sichern wir die grundrechte ausdrücklich
zum beispiel haben wir im gesetz
festgelegt dass die gesundheitsschutz
maßnahmen immer abgewogen werden müssen
auf ihre sozialen wirtschaftlichen und
gesellschaftlichen auswirkungen auch das
ist eine ganz wichtige maßnahme um die
grundrechte bei uns auch inter pandemie
zu sichern meine lieben kolleginnen und
kollegen wir brauchen bei den hohen
infektionszahlen dringend
schutzmaßnahmen aber es ist entscheidend
vor allem für die akzeptanz und das
vertrauen der bürgerinnen und bürger in
die schutzmaßnahmen dass dabei die
grundrechte auch in der pandemie
gesichert sind dass wir starke
parlamente haben und dass wir
rechtssichere rechtsgrundlagen für diese
maßnahmen schaffen das machen wir mit
diesem gesetz stimmte dem zu vielen dank
[Applaus]
und eine kollegin schöneburg fdp das
wort und bitte sie herr kollege vechta
wenn sie mögen dann auf beide
zwischenbemerkungen zusammen zu
antworten sie haben gegebenenfalls dafür
die doppelte zeit das geht dich nichts
verloren herr kollege bessere bitte
danke schön herr präsident ich habe auch
eine nachricht von den menschen die
diese diskussion leider nicht
mitverfolgen können
die sind nämlich mitten in der
demonstration vor dem reichstag und wir
schreiben uns jetzt gerade in diesen
minuten wo wir hier diskutieren werden
die wasserwerfer aufgefahren
die menschen werden dort die haben
geschrieben wir haben uns alle
hingesetzt und werden trotzdem mit
wasserwerfern beschossen
wie soll das friedlich bleiben wenn die
polizei gegen das eigene volk vorgeht
der etwas schreiben die menschen hier
bitte richten sie das allen
parlamentariern aus und ich frag sie die
menschen werden
der polizeieinsatz wurden angeordnet
wegen nichttragen der maske
die menschen werden wie viel zusammen
gekehrt weil sie angeblich keine
abstände
einhalten das ist schon dass der
vorgeschmack darauf was sie hier
mit ihrem gesetz durchdrücken personen
herr können ihre gedanken der
scherenburg sie brauchen nicht hier hin
zu bleiben herr pistor david 2 zwischen
kindern wieland schinnenburg jetzt als
nächste oder fdp mit einer zwischen
bemerken
zunächst wird bereinigt hat sich nach
diesem beitrag jetzt sprechen muss es
rein technisch klingt das nicht anders
muss leider zu sein möchte sie an die
sitzung des rechtsausschusses am montag
erinnern
da waren wir beide da und da wurde sehr
deutlich dass in dem § 28 jahren
fälschlicherweise nur ein kriterium
angesetzt wird für die schlussmann von
maßnahmen nämlich nur die inzidenz also
ihr fraktionskollege herr laute was soll
das müssten die mindestens noch das
alter der infizierten bugsiert werden
meine persönliche meinung ist noch
weitere kriterien dabei sein dann sagt
er eine andere kollegin aus ihrer
fraktion
ja da besteht die offenbar noch
nachbesserungsbedarf das müssen wir dann
später mal machen meinte frage ist
deshalb halten sie es für seriös wenn
ihre eigene fraktion feststellt besteht
nachbesserungsbedarf an eine ganz
entscheidende stelle dass sie dennoch
diesem gesetz zustimmen wollen ich halte
es nicht für siege ist was sagen sie
dazu
herr kollege dr fechner pflege die
ausschussmitglieder der spd im ausschuss
rechts in die personifizierte seriosität
das kann ich ihnen versichern
und sie müssen dann schon mal genau das
gesetz lesen dort steht insbesondere vor
den incidents zahlen und das gibt uns
die nötige flexibilität und ich möchte
auch noch mal ausdrücklich darauf
hinweisen dass zahlreiche fdp regierte
länder diesen gesetzesentwurf begrüßt
haben sogar teilweise gefordert haben
und dass wir auch in engem austausch mit
den rechtspolitikern ihrer fraktion zu
diesem wichtigen gesetz waren
und wenn jetzt kritisiert wird dass
polizei maßnahmen ergriffen werden dafür
weiß ich drauf als ich gerade eben
gesagt habe gerade weil uns das
versammlungsrecht so wichtig ist haben
die die hürden für eingriffe in die
versammlungsfreiheit sehr sehr hoch
gesetzt
nächster redner in dieser debatte ist
herr kollege uwe kammann
auch uwe kammann ist fraktionslos und
noch ein wort zu den demonstrationen in
der tat sind draußen wasserwerfer
aufgefahren
die begründung der polizei die
genehmigung station war nicht nur nicht
genehmigt sondern es wird keinerlei
schutzvorkehrungen eingehalten ich
selber habe die demonstration vor der
debatte gesehen da standen die
demonstranten in der tat das ist ja
verständlich sehr nahe zu standen
zusammen und vielleicht jeder zehnte
hatte eine maske auf 709 abgeordnete vom
volk gewählt mit einem
verfassungsgemäßen auftrag hier im
bundestag
wir sitzen hier nicht damit wir diesen
auftrag einfach weg delegieren können
diejenigen die für diese ausprägung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes stimmen werden
sollte sich überlegen ob sie tatsächlich
hier richtig sitzen denn sie wollen oder
können ihr mandat offenbar nicht
verantwortungsvoll erfüllen
der gesetzentwurf hat neben anderen drei
wesentlichen schwächen der datenschutz
wirklich ausreichend beachtet
die pandemie bewertung beruhen
ausschließlich auf subjektiven quasi
gefühlten kriterien statt auf
nachprüfbaren fakten
damit wird das tor für missbrauch
sperrangelweit geöffnet und ersparen wir
wissen nicht wer in zukunft hier das
sagen hat und die kontinuierlich
fehlende einbindung des bundestages ist
nicht hinnehmbar
alle drei elementaren möchten haben wir
main lkr parteikollege mario mieruch die
abgeordnete doktor petit und ich in
unserem änderungsantrag revidiert und
korrigiert wir sind nicht bereit
tiefgreifender einschnitt in die
grundrechte unserer bürger ohne solide
grundlage und beteiligung dieses
parlaments hinzunehmen
ich habe verliere an sie stimmen sie
deshalb unserem änderungsantrag zu
sollten sie dieses nach mäßig
und eine gestrickte gesetz ohne änderung
heute wieder mal im schweinsgalopp
durchwinken können sie sich jetzt schon
darauf verlassen dass das gesetz direkt
vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht landen
wird
welches licht das auf unser
bundestagsabgeordnete wirft können sie
sich selber denken
beginnen sie doch bei einem so wichtigen
thema einen breiten demokratischen
diskurs nicht nur wir sondern auch die
bürger werden es ihnen danken herzlich
dank zu zuordnen
in der debatte ist die bislang von der
cdu csu er ist der zuständige
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der union
der präsident meine damen meine herren
das ursprungs anliegen dieses dritten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetzes war die
grundlegung einer impfpflicht nochmals
keiner die grundlegende die nochmals
keine impfpflicht
und die vorfahren der testmöglichkeiten
das habe ich dieser tage einen
journalisten erklärt die antwort war uns
interessiert mehr der konflikt tausend
worte im deutschen bundestag wird dieser
konflikt gerade lautstark von
demonstranten ab tituliert warum das nur
ohne maske geht schließt sich mir nicht
frank herrmann geht beschwert habe ich
an der stelle aber verständnis auch ich
spüre diesen band liefert russe auch
meine grundrechte werden eingeschränkt
worauf führen mit für meinen für unsere
gesundheit und historisch war es üblich
für unglücke legen dass man sich nicht
wehren konnte ein sündenbock zu suchen
die politik ganz allgemein bietet sich
in modernen zeiten offenbar dafür an
doch liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
enttäuschen sie sich nicht gerade
richtung der alte am schluss wird da
nicht differenziert werden
[Musik]
das ganze als gutmann volksvertreter in
der seele weh
ich glaube aber dass wir uns klar sein
müssen dass wir das alle aushalten
müssen wir die mittel des deutschen
bundestags tragen die verantwortung von
tag 1 vom tag als wir die epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite
festgestellt haben bis zu diesem dritten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz deshalb mein
appell an der stelle an alle mitglieder
des wohnhauses
man kann über alles diskutieren über
alles debattiert stellen sie sich aber
nicht aus der verantwortung widerstehen
sie den versuch meine damen und herren
aus der pandemie ein politisches
geschäft zu machen kann die chancen die
sich ein kleiner teil der demonstranten
radikalisiert
bevor sie das nicht mehr etwa alle
seiten abgewogen argumentationen der
preis dafür ist zu hoch der wolf im
schafspelz sitzt wie immer ganz rechts
schauen sie die grundrechte
vorzuschieben um damit das vertrauen in
unseren rechtsstaat zu erschüttern
das ist ein geradezu der versus kalkül
muss man doch mal sagen genau das tun
sie ihr wart übrigen auch ich erwarte im
übrigen auch dass sich alle demokraten
des hauses hier gegen den begriff
rettungs ermächtigungsgesetz verfahren
gerade dass sie auch sie
nur sagen dass dieser historische bezug
bodenlos ist und wenn ist es noch an
fall erfüllen darf herr können müssen
sie mich wenn ich das noch anfügen darf
uniformen wie sie sich hier bisher an
torleuten tun keinem parlament gut zu
stellen sie eine zwischenfall verhafte
meiner präsidenten gestartet keine
zwischenfrage aus der afg das ist immer
dasselbe die von ihrem youtube-kanal
füllen und am schluss geschieht es nur
ausschnittsweise oder glauben sich in
der angst dass die art und weise wieder
bundesgesundheitsminister vorher in
ihren kollegen verschenkt hat dass das
auch bei der gelegenheit nicht auf
youtube gesendet das wäre schön
dann hätten sie mal auch der beitrag zur
wahrheit und klarheit unterstellen das
sollte dass er eine gute sache
28a des infektionsschutzgesetzes ist
meine damen und herren etwas was eben
das gegenteil ist von dem was ich ja als
ermächtigungsgesetz beschreiben wir
bestimmen 17 spezifische maßnahmen die
geeignet sind die ausbreitung des virus
zu verhindern
wir legen fest dass sich die länder bei
der auswahl dieser mittel an der dynamik
der ausbreitung zu orientieren haben wir
ziehen für besonders
grundrechtssensiblen verbote wie
versammlung gottesdienste oder besucher
ins seniorenheim klare grenzen und meine
damen und herren wir befristen die
eingriffe der länder auch vier wochen
verlangen klare begründung für
verlängerungen wo ist denn da eigentlich
ihre beschwere aber eine studie nicht
meine damen und herren wir übernehmen
nicht regierungshandeln oder die
zuständigkeit der länder
der deutsche bundestag kontrolliert die
regierung er ersetzt sie nicht und wer
sagt wir schaffen die demokratie
abgerückt
wir haben noch einmal ganz deutlich
sagen wir schaffen keinen impfzwang wir
sorgen dafür dass eine grundlage besteht
wo wir anschluss dann auch impfen kann
denn die frage wird doch nicht heißen
wer muss sondern wer darf und wann ich
bitte die menschen sich das mal vor
augen zu führen
bei all dem was wir momentan eine
argumentation hören der mir wichtig dass
sich die menschen draußen selbst ein
bild machen nicht alles glauben was in
den sozialen medien verbreitet wird und
dass sie sich immer eine frage stellen
cui bono wem nutzt das dann wäre viel
geholfen meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
hilde mattheis spd ist nix drin
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als wir im märz das erste mal
dass erste bevölkerungsschutz gesetz
diskutiert und debattiert haben war uns
allen klar
die handlung und die entscheidung liegt
beim parlament
und wir haben gesagt das parlament
entscheidet über eine epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite und das parlament
beendet diese tragweite und vor allen
dingen wir haben gesagt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn
zwischendurch sich die lage wesentlich
verbessert obliegt es diesem parlament
die lage zu beenden
und alles das hat am beginn dieser
debatte der afg nicht genügt da hat sie
gesagt ihr seid nicht restriktiv genug
ihr seid nicht konsequent genug
so begann diese debatte hier in diesem
parlament und jetzt drehen sie es rum
wir lernen dazu als parlament wir sagen
ja wir müssen genauer definieren wann
diese notlage eintritt das haben wir
jetzt gemacht da steht die definition
drin und daran müssen sich alle halten
wir haben gesagt wir erhöhen die hürden
für die maßnahmen wir erhöhen das
kontroll kontrollrecht für das parlament
die bundesregierung muss und darf hier
regelmäßig berichten
keine woche vergeht in der die
bundesregierung nicht in irgendeiner
weise über die pandemie berichtet und
wir nicht debattieren ich weiß nicht wo
sie waren
und dann
haben wir gesagt dieser vielstimmige
chor das ist doch etwas was die
zustimmung der bevölkerung ziemlich
anspannt wir wollen diesen vielstimmigen
chor der maßnahmen einschränken
wir wollen dass plan nachvollziehbar ist
wann in welchem land und bei uns im bund
welche maßnahmen getätigt wird das
machen wir jetzt und ich bitte um
zustimmung weil genau an der stelle
brauchen wir die akzeptanz der
bevölkerung und die licht hoch und ich
bin sicher dass mit viel transparenz und
auch mit einer klaren linie
diese akzeptanz uns nicht verloren geht
die wir brauchen und wir brauchen sie
denn wir wissen die zahlen und wir
wissen doch wie schwierig es im moment
ist und wir wissen die krankenhäuser
sind aufs äußerste angespannt die
situation pflegekräfte der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst alle an der
belastungsgrenze da müssen wir viel tun
ja und wir sind hier bereit im parlament
nicht nur zu diskutieren sondern auch
viel zu tun nicht nur über das dritte
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz und da gucke
ich mal in richtung plan korte also die
vermögenssteuer ist nicht im
infektionsschutzgesetz können wir gerne
diskutieren aber wir diskutieren wir an
diesem thema franken deshalb kollege
vielen dingen die auf unser
finanzminister auf den weg gebracht hat
schaffen wir auch die rahmenbedingungen
frau kollegin waters gestanden sie eine
zwischenfrage und deshalb liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen natürlich sind
wir ein lernendes system
die reagieren natürlich drauf was die
notwendigkeit ist und deshalb dieses
dritte bevölkerungsschutz gesetz
da sichern wir die grundrechte in dem
wir höhere hürden einbauen
wir machen die maßnahmen transparent
nachvollziehbar es gibt eine
begründungspflicht und in diesem ganzen
maßnahmen konzert hoffen wir auf die
zustimmung der bevölkerung denn wir
brauchen weitere anstrengungen und diese
pandemie einzugrenzen vielen dank ich
habe meine damen und herren und der
letzte redner zu dieser debatte um die
krone maßnahmen das
infektionsschutzgesetz im vorfeld
eigentlich heftiger diskutiert hier im
parlament ist jetzt thorsten frei die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der union dann sind die argumente
ausgetauscht und dann gilt es in die
abstimmung
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich finde im großen und ganzen
war das eine sehr gute debatte die
letztlich auch gezeigt hat dass das
alles nicht so ganz einfach ist weder
die situation in der wir sind noch die
frage wie wir damit umgehen und dass es
auch nicht so ganz einfach ist die
gratwanderung richtig zu schaffen auf
der einen seite als parlament sehr
konkret zu sagen unter welchen
bedingungen voraussetzungen in welchen
grenzen
die regierung und die regierungen
handeln dürfen und flexibilität gegeben
ist und auf der anderen seite es gelingt
zum schutze der körperlichen
unversehrtheit zum schutze der menschen
auch zum schutze der älteren und
schwächeren und kranken menschen das
notwendige zu tun und da haben sich
viele ich glaube auch in den
regierungsfraktionen mit sicherheit auch
in der fraktion der grünen es sich nicht
leicht gemacht und am ende des tages ist
es natürlich so dass worüber wir heute
abstimmen ist im zweifel nie ganz das
gelbe vom ei sondern es ist so wie es
wir sind eine demokratie immer ist am
ende ist es die kunst des kompromisses
und wenn es ein zustimmungspflichtiges
gesetz dann kommt es nicht nur darauf an
eine mehrheit hier im hause zu gewinnen
sondern nachher um 15 uhr auch im
bundesrat die länder davon zu überzeugen
dass es richtig und notwendig ist was
wir hier machen und genau das haben wir
getan
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich will
zunächst einmal den vorwurf zurückweisen
dass wir nicht auf die opposition
zugegangen wären und das gespräch
gesucht hätten
das war definitiv nicht der fall und es
war vor allen dingen so dass wir in der
vergangenen woche viele experten gehört
haben
wir haben auch in der expertenanhörung
miteinander gesprochen und sie haben ja
gesehen das was heute auf dem tisch des
hauses liegt ist etwas anderes als das
was wir am freitag vor einer woche hier
ins parlament eingebracht haben aus
meiner sicht ist es ein gutes zeichen
dass das parlament in der lage ist nicht
nur stolz an dem festzuhalten was es
eingebracht hat sondern daran zu
arbeiten es zu verbessern zu schauen wo
gibt es kluge hinweise auch von experten
wo gibt's auch kluge hinweise aus der
opposition die wir aufnehmen können um
das gesetz am ende besser zu machen und
genau das ist gelungen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
sehr klar die grenzen in diesem gesetz
geregelt unter denen die
landesregierungen tätig werden können
wir haben regel bei spiele gemacht und
keine standard maßnahmen damit die
flexibilität für die landesregierungen
erhalten bleibt in dieser krise
angemessen reagieren zu können
darum geht es und wir haben klar
festgelegt was sind die schwellenwerte
nach denen eingegriffen werden darf nach
denen schutzmaßnahmen ergriffen werden
dürfen
ich glaube es ist der richtige ansatz
dabei auf instanzen zu setzen weil es
ein frühindikator ist weil es zu spät
ist liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der fdp wenn man schaut wie die
auslastung der intensivbetten aussieht
dann ist es zu spät um angemessen
reagieren herr kollege 32 zwischenfragen
wünsche ich finde herr kollege zieht sie
in der ersten und hatte komme wenn ich
richtig informiert bin ja erst statt der
kollege von der hälfte bitte sehr
er muss noch das mikrofon eingeschaltet
bekommen vielen dank herr kollege frei
dass sie die gelegenheit geben das er
parlamentarisch eine zwischenfrage zu
stellen
die kollegen davor haben das leider
nicht gemacht wir haben die letzten
wochen und monate einschränkungen
erfahren in der freiheit der person bei
der versammlungsfreiheit bei der
freizügigkeit und eben auch wenn es um
die unverletzlichkeit der wohnung geht
das sind dinge die hier diskutiert
worden sind in diesem kontext machen sie
sich doch heute bitte ehrlich der grund
für dieses gesetz ist doch eigentlich
das stück für stück bundesweit ein
gericht nach dem anderen ihre maßnahmen
die sie getroffen haben als
verfassungswidrig eingestuft hat das ist
doch der eigentliche grund warum wir
hier heute zusammenkommen und darüber
diskutieren jetzt schaffen sie die
grundlage dafür dass die gerichte uns
zukünftig nicht weiter vor dieser
politik schützen können herr kollege
vereinzelt gut
sehr geehrter herr kollege frage
antworte ich will ihre frage gerne
beantworten wenn sie sich einmal die
gerichtsurteile in den vergangenen
wochen ansehen
dann sehen sie dass einzelne
verwaltungsgerichts urteile gab die
beispielsweise unter dem grundsatz der
verhältnismäßigkeit zu einem anderen
ergebnis gekommen sind und deswegen
einzelne regelungen in einzelnen ländern
aufgehoben haben es übrigens ganz
interessant dass andere
verwaltungsgerichte die
rechtsverordnungen anderer länder unter
dem gleichen gesichtspunkt gehalten
haben
aber da kann man sehen es kommt eben im
einzelnen auch darauf an wie eine
rechtsverordnung formuliert ist der
zweite punkt ist der wenn sie sich mal
anschauen die regelungen die wir bisher
hatten die bundesregierung und auch die
landesregierungen dort ist es der
paragraf 28 und 32 des
infektionsschutzgesetzes sind auf der
grundlage einer generalklausel tätig
geworden und wenn sie das letzte
obergerichtes dazu geurteilt hat
anschauen das bei den bayerischen
verwaltungsgerichtshof dann hat er
gesagt das die generalklausel
grundsätzlich eine möglichkeit ist für
solche maßnahmen aber dass man unter dem
gesichtspunkt dass diese pandemie und
die krise seit acht monaten andauern
dass wir auch in der tat sie haben es
beschrieben sehr tiefe grundrechts
beschränkungen hatten brauchen wir für
die zukunft eine konkrete gefasste eine
bestimmte rechtsgrundlage die schaffen
wir mit dem paragraphen 28a und im
übrigen auch mit dem paragrafen 5 absatz
1 wo wir eine legaldefinition der
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
vornehmen wir müssen nichts
rechtfertigen für die vergangenheit
geschaffenen grundlagen für die zukunft
weil wir wollen dass sowohl die
bundesregierung wie auch die
landesregierungen auch in zukunft in der
lage sind angemessen auf die pandemie zu
reagieren weil sie es nicht wissen weil
ich es nicht weiß und weil auch sonst
niemand weiß wie sich diese krise weiter
entwickeln danke
jetzt kommen die zwischenfrage des
kollegen tournee vielleicht zulassung
der zwischen frage sie sagten soeben das
auch für die opposition zugegangen
worden sein gesprächsangebot will ich
keinesfalls den vip raum entstehen
lassen dass wir auf dieses angebot nicht
eingehen würden
wir haben in der tat am wochenende
telefoniert weil ich nie an gesprächen
aussteigen kollegin zwei andere themen
graue wölfe und dergleichen mehr es ging
auch um 0 28 a
so kündigt mir in der tat an dass die
koalition aus dem für sie verheerenden
ergebnis der sachen anhören am
donnerstag konsequenzen ziehen würden
aber ein verhandlungsangebot habe ich
dem nicht entnehmen können was sollte
denn das für ein verhandlungsangebot
gewesen eine kollege frei und welchem
grund sollte das gehabt haben sitzt ist
sich etwa die koalition der stimmen ihre
situation so unsicher dass sie die
stimmen der opposition noch für sich
erwerben will
lieber herr thoma das ist richtig dass
wir am wochenende und auch ende letzter
woche mehrfach miteinander telefoniert
haben auch über unterschiedliche themen
und mir geht es ähnlich wie ihnen ich
genieße die gespräche mit ihnen deswegen
würde ich das umgekehrt auch nie
ausschlagen
aber in der tat sie haben natürlich
recht es kommt immer drauf an frau
hoffmann wir hatten uns auch darüber
unterhalten was verhandlungen und was
gespräche sind und da muss ich den
kolleginnen und kollegen der fdp einfach
sagen dass man richtig am text
verhandelt dann muss man entweder eine
landesregierung sein und dem bundesrat
einzustimmen zustimmungspflichtiges
gesetz haben
oder man muss eben hier im bundestag
mitregieren das hat die fdp
bedauerlicherweise ausgeschlagen und
deswegen müssen wir das anders handhaben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich will
ihnen eines sagen wir sind auch vieles
eingegangen auf die opposition auf
experten und anderes mehr
wir haben das gesetz verbessert und
bestimmter gemacht aber eines muss auch
klar sein bei allen rechten die der
bundestag hat und zwar vom anfang bis
zum ende
beim schutz von minderheiten hier im
parlament es ist auch zu respektieren
wenn eine mehrheit das anders zieht und
es ist gesagt worden 84 prozent der
deutschen sind entweder mit der
gesundheitspolitik der bundesregierung
zufrieden
oder sie glauben dass die maßnahmen
nicht einschneidend genug sind und ich
glaube dass das ziemlich genau hier in
diesem haus auch so ist und deshalb
müssen sie es ertragen wir bringen hier
heute einen antrag ein wir stimmen
darüber ab
wir stellen heute nochmals fest dass die
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
fortbesteht und deshalb sagen wir ganz
klar damit schaffen wir als
parlamentsmehrheit die rechte für die
bundesregierung und die
landesregierungen angemessen zu handeln
und ich möchte ganz zum
nur eines sagen an der stelle kommt es
nicht nur darauf an juristische seminare
zu bestehen an dieser stelle kommt es
auch darauf an etwas zum schutz der
menschen zu tun und da geht es auch
darum dass man auch wenn man nicht mit
allen zu 100 prozent einverstanden ist
bereit ist verantwortung zu übernehmen
verantwortung zu übernehmen
das hat auch etwas mit führung in
unserem land zu tun und das ist nicht
nur die aufgabe der bundesregierung das
sind hier alle gefordert herzlichen dank
[Applaus]